hello hello hello
how do i talk to real human beings
did we just start do we just start what
did we do what do we do
hello gamers and uh welcome to uh the
next episode of trash tastes [ __ ] i
started already midnight radio like
hello there you know i don't wanna i
don't even wanna wanna pretend i have
energy right now i'm coming in with a
chill coming in today
i don't know it's you're the host gone
you should come up with host energy
hello everyone and welcome to this
episode of trash taste i am your host
for today
was that was that enough energy connor
was that enough energy i don't know who
we are i'm uh i am gant and once again
i'm joined by my host connor and
i've certainly been in isolation so
um if you didn't know uh this is
actually the first time we filmed in uh
three weeks now because we took two
weeks two weeks
um i don't know about you boys but uh
not filming for like three weeks felt
like three years for me yeah yeah right
i'd like because especially for me right
because
i'm i go on twitter i go on social media
i see you guys you know streaming doing
all your [ __ ] and here i am just being
like oh just just in bed hill you know
just uh can't really talk content i
don't think anyone can fault you for
that right you're [ __ ]
yeah so if you didn't know i uh
unfortunately tested positive uh about
two weeks ago now it's been actually 15
days uh since i tested positive um now i
have officially tested negative so i am
safe to film again with the boys just in
case just in case i'm in like my own
isolation corner right here yeah
yeah
um but yeah i mean so i've been in
isolation for 14 days and how does it
feel how does it feel to get coded it it
it sucks okay i mean it like luckily
feels american
wow
i'm sorry we're british too
i had to it's for three weeks
it's been
america in three weeks
yeah so i like i remember when i got it
i was like i was honestly like a little
bit salty okay i was i was a little bit
salty not because obviously getting
covered sucks right yeah but uh i was a
little bit salty because before i got
covered i hardly ever went out at all
right i didn't go up because i spent all
this time
marathoning all like all the great anime
of 2021 to make my best of anime 2021
video so i was just like inside just
watching watching all the best [ __ ]
watching all this anime didn't go out i
went out aside from trash chase
recordings i went out once and the only
time i went out was with these boys
that was that was literally the only
time i went out in the past two weeks
prior to me catching kobe yeah right i
think i figured it out you think you
figured it out i know why you got it
okay okay i think the air when you're
six foot is high enough the covey was
traveling in the six foot sphere oh i
was
under the sun under the six foot
we couldn't breathe it in we couldn't
breathe
[Music]
that's the actual
scientific that we're not scientists do
not take over yeah
covert is the height equalizer
we needed this yeah we
needed six foot or something yeah yeah
yeah so i i remember i remember like
when obviously when i say positive i
remember messaging these boys being like
boys i gotta be honest you should
probably be careful because uh i'm not
gonna lie the only time i've been out in
the past two weeks has uh aside from
trash taste which i'm also with the boys
uh was with you guys when we uh went
after that one business meeting let me
just say i'm glad i got that text while
i was on the toilet because i did [ __ ]
myself
when i read that i was like oh my god oh
[ __ ] yourself if you weren't on probably
yeah
i was like thank god my pants are down
and i'm literally taking your [ __ ] yeah
so i was like brace yourself boys it
might come it might come um
yeah the storm's coming and then uh it
didn't come and apparently i was the
only one who uh got covered in uh in our
entire office i mean i say this because
i say this i'm happy that no one else
got a copy aside from me okay i'm i'm
i'm happy why didn't anyone else get it
i don't want to be the only ones but as
as the guy who does not you know the
only the only time i got to make content
is for trash taste you know you know you
boys filming outside going outside
filming them constantly i'm just like
why why why me why is it me why is it
the nerd that stays inside and watches
anime that gets covered anime gives you
curvy i'm telling you why do you think i
stopped watching it
yeah no because like uh guess yeah
because sydney got it as well right yeah
yeah yeah yeah sydney got it around two
days after me right right kind of makes
sense uh that was two days after my
symptoms that's it uh had set in and i
mean like i think i think uh i think i'm
glad that obviously i'm glad that i was
vaccinated and i think it was omicron as
well because my
symptoms weren't too bad i remember i
remember like i remember
i felt something coming and you know
like
you know when you wake up and you're
like eat like you have a bit of a sore
throat and you're like start [ __ ]
yourself yeah because you're just like
oh is this is this is this illness is
this it i'm am i getting ill am i
getting am i getting paranoid like i
remember on like the thursday night
because i've been paranoid before about
am i ill or am i not ill because i have
like a slight sore throat or like cough
or something but i remember thursday
night here and
like your body knows when it's about to
get ill or like i i could feel that my
body like that a storm was coming in my
body right and i was like praying to god
that it was just the flu or some kind of
normal other illness right but like
i kind of knew that something was coming
and i was like i told timmy sydney like
i think i'm about to get ill and i'm
like i'm like calling it now i'm like
i'm like calling it out i'm gonna get
ill
honey don't be mad promise you won't be
mad promise your way man i think i'm
about to get ill and uh and so like i i
didn't have a fever but like my body
started to feel like a little bit groggy
a little bit fatigued now i'm just like
i've felt this before i've felt this
before i've gotten like the flu or that
kind of like illness where like conks me
out for a few days so i'm like honey
don't be alarmed but i think i might be
old and then i went to sleep woke up and
i had a pretty high fever for me at
least like i remember when we did our
second vaccination i had like a fever of
like 38 degrees celsius i don't know
what that is in fahrenheit but uh on
that first day
on that it's not
on that first day on that first day i
started off with a 38 degree fever so i
was like okay i definitely got a fever
uh once you get tested and then by the
time night time came around that fever
had gone up to 40 degrees [ __ ] which
dangerous which is dangerous and i was
like i was like googling right i was
like googling when when should i like go
to the hospital why spoiler he lived
what is that what's the boiling point
yeah
because normally i normally when i get
the flu or something i go up to like 39
and i'm just like even then i'm that's
pretty really bad that's a really bad
call so i was like it was like i
remember measuring myself getting to 40
and then um
and then i remember googling how high
does your fever need to be to consider
going to the hospital and i remember
googling it and they said after around
41 degrees you should consider going to
the hospital right and me you already
drenched in sweat i start sweating even
more because i'm just like what do you
think what can i do there if you have a
fever it's like oh here's a bed lie down
like what can they what can they do like
placebo where like because you're in a
hospital you're gonna get better maybe
yeah maybe they're like oh he's an iv
maybe they give you like more stronger
maybe they give you more stronger
i mean like all i was going to say is i
mean i feel like it is a bit of a
placebo but also in case your symptoms
do get majorly worse there is someone
there to put you under intensive care
yeah yeah yeah yeah just in case but
absolutely terrified of hospitals it's
like the only thing i'm scared of no
same i don't really i don't know anyone
who goes to the hospital goes yeah but
some people don't mind they're like oh
whatever but i'm like i will literally
do anything not to go to the hospital
yeah which probably means that at some
point i'm probably gonna come down with
something and i should probably go and
get it checked out
because i'm i'm so stupid that i'll be
like no i'd rather not because
when i get ill right i just never ever
assume i should go to hospital yeah i
just think i should just write it out
you hear stories about how people die
from that
yeah because i feel like a lot of this
is part of i mean i i think a lot of
this is part of growing up in england as
well because i think there was there's
definitely a difference in mentality
when it comes to illness especially when
i started started you know dating sydney
and seeing how she handled getting ill
versus how i handled getting ill because
i'm just like if i have a high fever i'm
just like just just take some
paracetamol ride it out whatever just
just like start putting in bed yeah
sweat it out sweat it out you know uh
like because in england if you go to see
the doctor by the time you book an
appointment and you get the chance to go
see the gp um you it's like the fever is
already gone right the fever's already
gone you're either better or dead yeah
yeah so so it's either you're bad enough
to go to the hospital yeah or you just
don't go to the doctor at all yeah
but like with sydney because luckily
sydney had health insurance when she was
in uh when she was growing up in america
stop breaking
showing sydney's privilege right here
yeah she had health insurance okay wow
health insurance but uh uh so she would
be like you know if she just got
slightly old just go see the doctor just
to make sure just just in case you use
that health insurance
use that health insurance because you
can just go see yourself so why would
you not go see a doctor me being me
dying in bed being like i don't see
sydney i don't need to see a doctor i
don't see a doctor why would i need to
see a doctor it's only like a 40 degree
fever google says i need to be 41 to go
see your doctor sydney come on come on
i'm safe i'm saying i ain't a [ __ ] boy
ain't a [ __ ] boy
that's true though in japan people like
that as well i think yeah yeah yeah
people they're like i've got a headache
i'm going to the clinic what what what
no no no
yeah i don't know just sleep it off i
don't know maybe i'm being too harsh
like but then do you find that sometimes
you're like i don't know if this is a me
thing but sometimes i'm getting sick i'm
like no yeah stop body stop
stop right now
don't do this
develop men i think i like have i don't
know if this is just like me being
stupid but i just completely ignore it
when i'm like about to get sick i'm like
we are not sick we will continue with
our day like everything is normal that
just sounds like copium to the max
sometimes i feel like it works though i
don't know it's cause i don't know if
this is pure luck or it's it's probably
my own stupidity like sometimes i get
ill i feel like the illness coming and
then in my mind i feel like this is like
a deciding point in my head i'm like am
i going to resign myself to being ill or
am i going to be like no i'm not ill i'm
going to continue on i'm going to eat
healthy i'm going to do it this sounds
like some joe rogan-esque [ __ ] i'm
saying right now it's not i don't know
like for small illnesses obviously if
you've got some kind of horrible illness
it's like yeah no the flu is controlled
by the government of mind power
well you know it's like it's like the
placebo effect right how like this could
be complete like nonsense but we are not
medical professionals
we're gonna say
when it's like a tiny illness right it's
like a sore throat you know something
like that yeah sometimes i feel like how
much of your like mental
mental willpower can affect it because
you hear about you know uh the the
placebo effect
affecting how you can perform in certain
situations yeah yeah i'm wondering like
how much can that affect your your
likeliness to get sick
i mean i i do feel like you're
oh okay this is going to be complete
speculation this is all anecdotal yeah
any medical professional is
completely anecdotal but i do feel like
your mentality and your willingness to
like i don't know accept something it
does i think i feel like it does play
like some kind of subconscious effect
right because you you hear like
you hear about stories about people who
you know have like a deadly illness and
because they are have like the will to
fight it you know they
you know some people are able to fight
through the illness and some people are
more inclined to give in you know yeah
yeah so i i do feel based on zero
zero [ __ ] scientific proof and just
based on total anecdotal evidence that
there is some kind of effect that your
mentality has towards illnesses
sometimes sometimes not every time you
know i'm
just the dark souls of illnesses guys
come on you just you just gotta get good
you just gotta take it no that's not i'm
not trying to say i'm saying it's like
with like little things with like colds
and stuff yeah yeah i feel that like
when i'm way more up for being like [ __ ]
you i'm gonna just continue with my day
mentally i don't know why it's not it's
not like you do anything to actually
like prevent it right it's not like you
like taking the [ __ ] no i i'm
honestly whatever i go out of my way to
not take anything like i don't i don't i
never take painkillers
to me like taking painkillers is the
point that i admit defeat and i am
actually ill you know yeah
you know what i mean like it's like
because i'm at like even this time when
i like i could feel my body like getting
ill i was like no no it's it's not it
i'm not i'm not ill like i'm not gonna
go out obviously because because it's a
pandemic but i'm gonna i'm gonna keep
working i'm gonna go buy my daily
schedule and i woke up and i'm like 38
that's that's like that's like a
manageable fever i'll get i'll get
tested come back
it's pretty [ __ ] high
like it's to me to me it was manageable
until like i remember like sitting
sitting at my pc uh on the first day
that the symptoms started you know
started rolling in obviously at this
time i didn't get any of the test
results so i had no it could have been
like a cold for all i knew and i was i
remember sitting down at the computer
trying to work and it was just i as the
day went on i was like no body don't do
this don't know you're not ill you know
what come on buddy you can power through
this and i remember it was around like
five o'clock where i was like staring at
the script and i was like trying to get
[ __ ] done and i just like it just like
no words would come out because i was
just too tired i was like
okay i'm actually [ __ ] ill let's let
me take some [ __ ] medicine let me
take my temperature again and let me
like do do the [ __ ] just imagine
you're sitting at your computer
[Music]
[Applause]
illness is just a perception man it's a
perception it's same with like i don't
know like painkillers and stuff like
that i have friends who
will you know they'll take a painkiller
the moment they even get a slight
headache yeah but i'm always like really
bored because then they i s the same
people like this is completely anecdotal
they're just like oh yeah well i i it
doesn't work as well anymore because i
take it too often and i'm like well
that's scary yeah i'm just not gonna
take it unless unless i'm really really
in pain and then i'll be like alright
fine because then what happens if they
you know get like say like a really
massive headache or you know worse still
like where it's like oh god if you don't
have pain medicine you're just you're
just [ __ ] you might think yeah you
might pass out whatever i always worry
about stuff like that yeah yeah i mean i
think the only scary thing for me uh was
because i'd never gotten covered before
like normally when i get an illness i've
been ill enough times to know how my
body deals with it right you know like
okay i'm gonna be out for x amount of
days i need to do this like i've got
this down to a science right you know i
i you know i wake up with you know like
um like what's what's the what's the
throat itis uh tom slice or something
you know which has happened a few times
i'm just like okay i'm gonna be calming
out for two days i'm not gonna be able
to speak for like three four days and
then afterwards i'll be completely fine
right but when i tested positive i'm
just like [ __ ] i've never i've never
done this before so this is all new
territory for me man like how's my body
gonna react with i've got asthma is that
gonna play an effect i'm just like i it
it wasn't like this i didn't have a bad
time it was more of just like the
unknown that uh that scared me the most
right
because it was something completely new
that i had never experienced before so i
had no prior knowledge about how i
should best deal with it or how my body
was going to deal with it luckily it was
fine second thing that i kind of [ __ ]
myself over was the uh everyone's saying
that you might lose your sense of taste
i'm just like you know what i i think uh
i think i'd rather go to hospital than
lose my sense of taste honestly what do
you mean with the bread take you surely
do i think a lot of people argue that
you already
i don't think you have any taste buds to
kill
you you know like the first thing that i
did when i tested positive was obviously
i needed to inform male 1 to like inform
geeks plus and everything in the office
that i tested positive and the first
thing she messages me about is oh uh
i've heard that uh covered might like
change your taste buds so maybe you'll
be able to taste bread now i'm just like
[ __ ] you melon
were you did you were you hungry at all
did you have an appetite when you
it was like exactly the same okay so
like here's the thing i hate about being
[ __ ] ill right is that it's like i i
didn't lose my sense of taste but like
it was just the same
like effect to your taste that you have
with any illness which just for some
reason everything just tastes [ __ ]
everything just tastes bland man i get
super hungry when i get sick yeah i
remember like so weird that's because
remember when you got ill like the few
weeks before when you got like
tonsillitis yeah you just ate a [ __ ] ton
and to me like i i can't eat at all i
mean when i'm ill i just i just don't
assuming my stomach is okay and like i
have any other illness i'll just eat a
lot i don't know why for me when i'm
sick like just the smell of food is like
that one time food poisoning i got food
poisoning this one time and then the
next day while i was still dying i got
so hungry i felt like mcdonald's
so i ordered like a [ __ ] ton of
mcdonald's and i ate all of it yeah i
weirdly i felt a lot better i don't know
why i feel like i'm the only person on
earth who binged mcdonald's and then
felt better yeah yeah because usually
that's the thing that gives you food
poisoning yeah that's exactly right
you think mcdonald's after having food
poisoning it's a bold choice it was
really weird you're like really doubling
down it was okay actually the one time i
do regret doing this one time i was
really sick again i think with food
poisoning the next day i know everyone's
gonna laugh i decided to get indian
curry
that was actually a mistake
why would you do that i was really
craving like butter curry i don't know
why i
you know i i crave a lot of good food
when i'm ill as well but i'm like i
i've had it enough times that you regret
it immediately yeah you take the first
bite that was the only time i've
regretted it other times i've gotten it
and i feel better i don't know if it's
like in my mind i'm like yeah this maybe
my body's like oh [ __ ] we got another
problem to deal with let's deal with
that and then everything just gets
better yeah i don't know i don't know
it's it's low [ __ ] really your brain
works one step at a time
i don't know it's all it's all weird i
feel like i no one really understands
their body we're all just guessing we're
all just doing we're like we're like
we're like uh
plague doctors trying to figure out our
thing with our own weird rituals i think
we all just have a thing that we feel
comfortable with and somehow it works
we've sorted it we've done we've been
ill enough times to know kind of how our
body reacts to certain things and to
deal with certain things everyone bodies
is different yeah i'll sit there and
like laugh at all these plague doctors
from the 18th century and then i'll just
be like i'm gonna will power my disease
away and so i'm like it's only really
have we changed at all i don't think so
i think i think we've just gotten
smarter wow you know i'll fix my sore
stomach mcdonald's dude exactly that's
what i'm saying wait but like before
covert like how often did you guys get
sick like per year once a year
yeah
food poisonings i feel like food
poisoning to me seems to get food
poisoning a lot food poisoning to me i
don't count us getting like sick
no that's definitely
that is illness that is illness hit me
up because it's like it's like uh if if
i poisoned god you wouldn't be like oh
god god got sick you're like god was
poisoned right it's a different kind of
vibe it's just sickness you know what i
mean it's not like you treat it's like
you got food poisoning yeah you you
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] just deal with it
wait
do you know what food poisoning is yes
because it's not like someone slipped
cyanide into your mouth no i know i know
but it's like it's like it's not caused
by like a natural cause of like sickness
or a bacteria or virus it's like
something went wrong no it is it is it
is it is i know i know but it's not like
you got it by accident or something you
know what i mean like you stumble across
it it's like something had to go wrong
for it to be there no i think it's by
accident right yeah no no no no you you
wouldn't know something's wrong with the
food unless you try it
i know right that's what i'm saying like
i don't count that as like the natural
quota of getting sick because like let's
say you undercooked chicken and there's
salmonella in it that's just like that's
[ __ ] you're done yeah but that's not
the fault of the person who cooked the
chick under cookie chicken that's the
fault of the salmonella that's where you
cook the chicken which is the disease
that comes right right yeah but that's
like you would ever come across
naturally right that's not something you
would normally come across like let's
say what do you mean by come across like
like just like on the street
something like carried like gaunt is
like carrying like a normal i don't know
a cold or whatever right it's different
category in my mind i don't know well
like not every raw piece of chicken has
salmonella
there is a chance that if you have a raw
piece of chicken and it's not cooked
then the salmonella or the batter so we
have steps
in the same way that if you uh if you go
outside and someone has covered or the
flu or something and you stand next to
them and they cough and then you inhale
you have a chance particles then you
have the chance of getting it it's right
in my mind i should put it differently
because food poisoning is normally just
due to the lack of like somebody [ __ ]
up
right you mean lack of
lack of like under cooking yeah yeah
undercooking and stuff like that or bad
bad stuff not all the time though just
sometimes they'll just be like a road
like e coli and [ __ ] yeah that's that's
yeah that's a big [ __ ] up sometimes it's
just a matter of like oh you know there
was a piece of food there and just you
know unfortunately just a rogue you know
disease or virus just happened to
[ __ ] stumble upon oh i mean you
inhale it's different though right
because then we are you saying that food
poisoning is more preventable yeah way
more preventable well that's why you can
be like your restaurant can be shut down
if you keep giving people food poisoning
oh yeah it's the majority of the time
something like food poisoning is due to
somebody [ __ ] up in the in the chain
of pro like
so basically the the most time to get
ill is uh when
someone has [ __ ] up and given you food
poisoning yeah or you [ __ ] up and
giving yourself mainly me i look at it
and i'm like ah [ __ ] it
mentality now it's not an illness
i don't know it's just different in my
head
i don't know about you i count food
poisoning as an illness i do count food
boys but then again i've gotten i don't
get sick often but i think i've only
ever gotten food poisoning maybe like
twice in my life i didn't get it much
till i came to japan i've had it many
times in japan weirdly really yeah like
four i've never gotten food poisoning in
japan yeah i've never gotten food
poisoning in japan i've got it
like the worst food poisoning i've
gotten was in china um and also
sometimes in thailand as well i think
yeah i got really bad food poisoning in
the philippines yeah i think you know um
but i think food poisoning in southeast
asia is just like part of the experience
right yeah
and uh yeah
yeah
i never knew you could get food
poisoning from a mango but i i
definitely got it from a mango like that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up dude
i swear to god every time sydney has
oysters she gets like [ __ ] food
poisoning and every [ __ ] time she's
like maybe this time i won't maybe this
time maybe like i hear like you hear you
know that every now and then there's
like there's those foods that's like
yeah food poisoning central right yeah
oysters being one of them yeah that is
poor storage i've never gotten it from
oysters it's so weird you probably only
eat eaten oysters here in japan right no
no everywhere really yeah i had it in
the us australia everywhere and i've
never gotten it that's a gamble in the
uk really yeah it's very much a gambling
uk and i think a lot of places in the us
as well because it depends how well they
store it or how fresh it is human error
scene this is why it's why don't you
count the same in my head
if somebody sneezes at me in public i'm
like that can't be helped you know
whatever but if somebody if somebody
forgot to [ __ ] freeze a piece of fish
then served it to me someone [ __ ] up
and made me sick
how is someone sneezing on you not a
human error well no you like let's say
you're in a plane right someone four
suits behind you sneezes whatever they
didn't they didn't react quick enough i
feel like that's not that's they can't i
can't possibly react i could i couldn't
then go to like court and be like this
person sneezed on the plane behind me
and didn't cover up their face you know
i feel like it's not you can't hold
someone accountable whereas like let's
say somebody just didn't store a piece
of fish properly that's like negligence
on their part and then they served it
yeah i get that that's the why i don't
treat it the same but i don't treat it
the same either but it's still an
illness yeah it's it's
regardless
i feel like because it's like not
a way to i i don't that's like okay
would you count cancer as an illness
then you don't get cancer from eating
fish
but what i'm saying is it's you treat it
completely differently but it's still an
illness right yeah but like that's true
you can just get right that's just like
different because that's like
that that most the time lung cancer yeah
yeah what if like you you smoke enough
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's on you
and then in that case i wouldn't build
illness
you know stuff like that it's like it
only raises your chances right where
it's like if somebody just gives you
flat out a completely like [ __ ] up
piece of fish or meat that's been stored
in properly you're gonna get sick 100
right whereas like you there are people
who have been chained smoking from my
age 10 to 100 who don't get it right so
it's complete luck on that part but with
the with the with the storage food and
all that that's like all right somebody
[ __ ] up you know what i mean that's
categorically someone just [ __ ] up and
they gave it to you and poisoned you
that's what it is it's different to like
getting an illness it's totally
different
doctors in the comments are cracking up
right now i have this conversation
yeah i actually want to know what people
think about this i feel like i'm not the
only one who thinks this way towards
like food poisoning this is not a weird
thing i mean i i just i it's just you
getting ill i'll just
say like if you ask me how often do i
get ill i wouldn't count that because
that's got nothing to do with like
an illness no it's not you're literally
sick if if i were to just like make
myself vomit would you say like i've
gotten an illness no well then why would
food poisoning count towards that
because it's a literal disease well
that's got nothing no comment to like
how often you get ill that's how often
you eat bad [ __ ]
no
yeah
no that's entirely different i mean it
all depends on your environment right
but obviously if you know if if you're
in an environment where a lot of you
know where like a lot of people are ill
we're going through a wave of illness
then you're more likely to get ill in
the same way if you live in an
environment where people are you know
where people are less
careful with their food preparation then
you're more likely to get ill you know
that's that's right that is the thing if
you go to southeast asia or you know a
lot of places where the food standards
aren't as high no like it's true it's
true it's true
i'm i'm i'm not i'm not throwing shade
i'm just saying facts here okay guys i'm
saying faxing you know you go to a
[ __ ] street vendor on the street
you're just like how was how is this me
prepared where did this me come from
they don't [ __ ] know
you from the back of my truck yeah
exactly right exactly you know
um i mean
i mean it's it's all it's it's all risk
it's all risk at the end of the day you
know you can eat raw chicken in japan
you know it's still and apparently here
it's more safer because
uh because you know food standards here
in japan are higher i don't know how
true that is how not true it is but at
the same time you're still taking a risk
what if your stomach's just weak well no
i mean if the restaurant just gives me
like poorly stored sausage i think
that's their fault you know that's
that's not that's why because the one
thing i learned from when i was in the
philippines is that like yeah the food
standards are a lot lower than normal
but people don't get sick because they
just naturally have more of like a
resistant stomach
right from living there always yeah i'd
say that's true actually not with
everything though
not with everything not with everything
but with a lot of things that visitors
to those countries would immediately get
sick oh yeah i wouldn't say of a weak
stomach i normally don't really have any
problem with like gross foods or
something that's a little off
but i mean there are times where i've
eaten something and then i've gotten
really sick and i was like why did i eat
that well what what do you what do you
count as food poisoning then
because like okay you okay you you go
you go to like you go to a country give
me an example like throw things at me
and i'll be like food poisoning or not
okay you go you go to a country right
you taste something that your body has
never like tasted before it's like
totally new cuisine and your body's just
like oh that's not food poisoning i
don't like this and then you get like
the [ __ ] for like five days no that's
not food poisoning [ __ ] isn't the food
poisoning yeah yeah if
it comes back up
that's food poisoning
so to me it's like you need to have like
you know your body is literally you know
physically reacting in some way where it
gives you like a fever or a headache or
vomiting you know where i never get
normal i never get anything like that
from eating food but when i when i do
eat like i can normally remember what it
was that gave me it because i
i very much felt rough immediately after
eating yeah because i count food
poisoning as i am conked out yeah in bed
yeah
yeah
i've got a fever because that is
it's literally like a bacterial
infection
i think if it makes you feel a little
queasy and it gives you the [ __ ] no
that's not that's just you do have a
weak stomach for that yeah but i think
if you're if you're throwing up you're
you have a fever yeah you you have food
poisoning that's what i would yeah but
then like i wouldn't in my mind if that
happens to me let's say i
you know you get that once a year oh
lately it's been more it's been like
what two three [ __ ] i've only had that
like a few times in my life
i order a lot of food right i never cook
myself so yeah
yeah i don't know i think it happens a
lot more also
that's what i'm saying i think it's you
i think it's just you no it's not it's
not me
i'm not the one cooking i think you just
have a weak stomach no no no no no
because it's happened where it's not
just been me who gets sick from the food
like other people have gotten sick or
with me right right so maybe they have
weak stomachs too no that's not
that is not a good defense your honor
why did you give people a cold like oh
it's got wicked stomachs in it somebody
started it they didn't get good but you
call it no no no that's not how it works
because i i out of the last three times
i got food poisoning two times it was
sausage and i can distinctly remember
eating the sausage and being like hmm
really pink really really pink and i was
like i think it's okay
i'll eat it and then i regretted it
after
so i learned that and the other bag was
the other one was from a a bag of
flaming hot cheetos that it was like
four months off
well well that again sounds like yeah
so that's mine right but when i
okay let's say i i'm an idiot and i eat
a four-month-old bag of flamin hot
cheetos right
to me if i start throwing up that in no
way in my mind is in the same category
as like let's say i got a i got
tonsillitis or something because this is
like this is me being a [ __ ] idiot
yeah and then i immediately got
consequences for it right the only
difference is like let's say i got to a
restaurant is that i didn't cook it but
somebody's still [ __ ] up right let's
say the sausage was awful like so in my
head it's not in the same category as
getting like a an infection from just i
don't know where the [ __ ] i got it from
right because it's like somebody [ __ ]
up with the flaming hot cheetos i [ __ ]
up i'm massively [ __ ] up yeah all
right here's the thing okay so
you go to a convention all right all
right you go to a convention yeah you
party for like every like every day at
the convention you get confluent yeah
right
everyone gets [ __ ] conflict yeah a
lot of people get [ __ ] up of course
does that does that count as the same
thing because you know like you're going
to a place where you know that you're
probably going to get infected with
something along the way because there's
a lot of people in a single area and
you're putting yourself in a position
where your immune system is going to be
weaker because you're naturally doing a
lot of [ __ ] does that count as this
illness which category to the future
yeah where which does corn flu count as
anyone getting sick like normal sick
getting normal sick yeah normal that's
not that's not food poisoning i feel
like food poisoning it is in its own
complete like category closer to like
self-poisoning to me
in my head
i don't know how do you understand why i
think that way or you just don't get it
at all i understand why you think that
because i understand i just don't agree
because it's not like i'm going to the
con and i'm going around licking floors
and i'm licking you know what i mean
like i am just i i know that you're at a
higher risk because you're around a lot
of people yeah people
some people who aren't
sometimes you shake a hand or you're
just like oh i don't know i better like
sanitizer sometimes you know like my
hand is getting sick yeah yeah yeah yeah
and because we're taking photos we're
getting close people yeah people want
you know people yeah i understand that
that's just like a big risk sometimes i
get conflict sometimes i don't but
that's that's again like it's like
that's like me almost squishing like six
months of interacting into one weekend
so to me it makes sense right that you
would there was a very high chance you
could get a six yeah yeah but again like
it's not the same with food poisoning
because again somebody had to [ __ ] up
in my head
i wonder if i'm like the only i can't be
the only person who sees it this way
there must be a lot of people i mean
you're the first in my head you're the
first person how many people have you
discussed this with right this is not a
normal thing to discuss yeah it's not a
normal thing to discuss because i think
in for most people
food poisoning is an illness
there's like no question about it if you
asked me connor what's up why can't you
come in the trip's recording there i
might be like i've been poisoned i'd be
like no i got sick i gotta say but then
in my head i would have this this
category that i would label it just
happens to now we have to talk about it
and i'm explaining it and i didn't
realize that people didn't see it this
way so the next time you get food
poisoning and you say oh sorry guys i'm
sick i'm allowed to call you out on that
or yeah you can be like who [ __ ] up
yeah
i'll be like i'll be like did you eat
another [ __ ] bag of flavored hot
cheetos
at the restaurant this time
who's the culprit here's the thing right
if i get sick from a restaurant and you
only know me it's like oh oh connor are
you let's say you don't know like let's
say this restaurant is poisoned like a
hundred other people then you would
start being like what the [ __ ] is going
on why is this restaurant still opening
the only difference is that you only
hear my side right but obviously
normally a restaurant wouldn't be doing
that but still
i'm not crazy this is just it's
perception you know we have i sound like
alex [ __ ] jokes
with the water you're just hearing one
side of the story it's like no i don't i
agree that food poisoning is very hard
to argue without sounding [ __ ] insane
i i agree with that food poisoning is in
the different category than let's say
the flu or tonsillitis but i would say
that there are a lot of illnesses that
exist that can exist in different
categories from the flu and food
poisoning and a lot of things but at the
end of the day some in my mind
they're all illnesses
yeah but in my head i don't treat them
the same way like like like there are
millions of different illnesses with a
million those millions of different ways
to prevent it uh to stop yourself from
getting ill or all this kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] in mind that this is not like some
kind of hard scientific definition i put
in my head this is just like a mentality
i have towards thinking don't worry
people don't come to trash
but there's always so many comments
being like i'm gonna post some holes
through conor's thoughts and it's like
well yeah because i didn't really think
that much about it anyways it's just
talking out of his arms she's got a
rough rough uh estimation i just don't
see the benefit in labeling food
poisoning as a different thing
i
feel like that's more of like copium on
your end to be like
i'm not ill i'm not ill why why not just
say their own illnesses i don't know
because again this isn't something that
i ever discussed with people right not
something that comes out in the open
often obviously now i'm having to talk
about it for a million plus people but
that was not my intention this is just a
soft definition in my head towards how i
viewed the illness this episode is
sponsored by honker impact third with
the girl in both black and white let's
welcome shiksel's strongest valkyrie
bianca taginer the most awesome one in
version 5.5 must be the drendel who is
the first valkyrie to have black and
white forms just look at her costume and
we would know that she's a cruel beauty
especially designed for drandal the new
battle suit palatinus equinox is also
available in two alternative forms they
are knight and guardian respectively the
switch itself has skill effects too it's
like owning two battle suits guys in
addition to new characters and battles
hong kong back third also prepared four
new outfits for two valkyries what's
more exciting if you get one outfit of
the valkyrie you can unlock the other
one automatically they're just giving
them away since version 5.5 is also
designed for celebrating the anniversary
of the global server logging in rewards
a fourth anniversary emblem not to
mention a variety of upgrade materials a
large sum of cards and crystals the
spring event also rewards a new s-rank
battle suit spina stira and an s-rank
battle suit option s-rank battle suit x2
surprises are also delivered outside of
the game lots of captains have
well-prepared fan art works from the glb
4th anniversary it'll be released on the
26th of february come and join the hong
kong carnival more excitement can be
found there so what are you waiting for
download hong kong impact third today
and use the gift code on screen for a
bunch of freebies the rewards are 30
crystals 2 888 asteroid and a herschel
trial card they get a whole going back
third for sponsoring this episode back
to the show okay so but obviously if
you're like e coli i wouldn't count that
the same as regular food
so bringing this back to how we start
this conversation how does this even
come out how often do you normally get
ill
that's how that's counting food
personally
once a year maybe okay okay including
food poisoning oh that's exponentially
[Applause]
yeah that's three of them with food
poisoning though right so one
so like this
one
so like aside from this time the last
time i got ill was literally like two
years before this i don't get ill often
very rarely i very rarely get ill as
well like i very i very rarely get ill
to the point where i cannot
like i kind of work yeah yeah that i
need to actually like take a take a rest
and take a break because i feel like i
don't know i feel like my body
obviously this is all talking [ __ ] i
feel like my body even if like the whole
episode's [ __ ] yeah because like
there's been there's been points where
sydney has been like [ __ ] cocked out
in bed with a high fever and all that
[ __ ] and i get like a mild cough and
that's just that's just it and yeah and
she's conked out for two days and i'm
just like
um how are you doing honey how are you
doing honey this is
sick people i get way more scared oh
yeah it freaks me out i don't know why
is this like a human uh reaction that we
have
i
that
we're
like
natural to be afraid of it yeah yeah i i
feel like that's a big natural human
reaction because yeah you just you you
are adverse to getting ill you know
you're here you are adversely people are
sick people die there it's like why
would you enjoy a place where people die
back when i had him uh when i got back
when i had it when it's genetic what the
[ __ ]
um
that's cute i'm curious it's just a
state of mind
that [ __ ] away
boom just like that fly food poisoning
yeah
so uh i had to go to the hospital a lot
when i was a kid because i had to get my
blood tested like every uh three months
or something or every six months or
something like that
far too often for my liking yeah um and
i hated it because i had to like sit
there for like four hours get a test
wait get another test and get results
and stuff and then the whole time i was
just surrounded by like
very very ill people and it was always
just like really scary it's like an
eight-year-old and didn't like keep
growing up and just keep seeing this and
like oh yeah uh-oh uh-oh and all the
offices of like the doctors have always
liked really cluttered they're really
messy and i was like i was like ah
i think i think the one thing i hate
about the hospital the most is the smell
yeah the smell yeah it's like the smell
of a hospital is just like oh it's like
it's hard to explain that there was yeah
there was also like it smells of illness
yeah yeah literally you know like like i
said when when you're ill and when i was
ill things just smell and taste
different you know yeah of course
naturally and it it [ __ ] sucks but
like when you go to a hospital for some
reason you get that same smell where
it's just like man everything just
smells stale you know yeah
it's the stale smell like like the magic
like the color has been like taken out
of everything you know
like that's how i feel when i'm ill i
don't know it just feels like it just
feels like life gets gets like a black
and white fill to be put onto it do you
like the smell of the dentist
no
because i know people who love the smell
of the dead what is the smell of the
dentist oh sweeney todd what the [ __ ]
it's like it's like
it's like the smell of like uh
i don't know what it's it's the smell of
uh like
i don't know how do you how do you
describe the small things i don't i
don't go bro i'm british we don't go to
the game
i don't know i i don't smell the dentist
often i'm couched in and out i want to
get out there soon it smells like clean
teeth but in like the worst way possible
well it smells like chemicals it's the
only way yeah i guess i never i never
really thought about it it smells like
like hand sanitizer yeah like that kind
of fresh kind of flavor but like it's in
medical places it smells like the
sterile eyes yeah it smells clean but
not in a good way
really yeah because like you know when
you think of like say you know something
that's clean right like you know like
scented hand sanitizer or whatever right
or like you know febreze or whatever
right like usually it's like oh that's a
good smell like that's like a refreshing
smell but like hospitals and dentists
for me are just like it's clean but
something no the hospital and dentist is
smell different to me like no they're
very very like i feel they're in like
the same like category of like it's
clean but it's not it's not like a good
clean
it's like too clean
where it's like nothing's here anymore
levels of clean like it's sterilized is
a good word yeah so it's it's sterile
which i hope they are
i would very much hope that they are
sterile you know
the smell yeah
apparently dentist smell of clove oil
and tooth dust
clove oil and tooth dust what the [ __ ]
is this
oh
like literally the dust gross
yeah oh you know what
i don't know i have
yeah it just smells like chlorine
no
it it has like a faint chlorine
maybe maybe the dentist
i don't know if it's like what they're
shoving in
or whatever but like it smells like
chlorine how often do you guys go to the
dentist i try to like twice a year just
it just is like a checkup
did you like put it in your cause like
british culture
british culture we we don't go to the
dentist like a lot and i only really
started going uh actually like we i
would normally only go to the dentist
before when i'd go to like asia and then
yeah like because like dentists were
actually like really much cheaper i am i
am before the all the british tooth uh
jokes in the comments now
but like
do do you have like a schedule of like
oh it's been like three months or six
months i was like where are you yeah
they say i think they say when you're an
adult you should go at least two or
three times a year as for like a checkup
right i don't [ __ ] know well like you
know because the good thing with the
dentist is that like even if you don't
have like the cavity or you're not
hurting anywhere like they'll at least
just like [ __ ] clean your teeth yeah
yeah i hated them clearing my teeth
though i wasn't drilled so loud oh the
water like pressure thing right yeah
yeah yeah in japan in japan it's
horrible no like to me i think the worst
feeling is like getting a filling and
like i don't know just like have you got
a feeling before i've gotten one before
right and i don't know that like that
experience as a kid just scarred me for
life right because just like i don't
know what it is about just
like just hearing the drill and just
like not being able to see what they are
doing to your mouth and just like do you
want do you want to see do you want tv i
i don't know i don't i don't know what's
scarier right because you know it's like
i need to see this in 4k
i think it can be arranged
no because like just i i i it's like
that feeling of just when they hit like
a nerve ending for just a second yeah
like
like like i i
i i feel that in my nightmares you know
[ __ ] i like ever since i heard felt
that was a kid the first time i just
that put me off going to the dentist
ever again yeah um the worst the worst
for me is when you hear the drill sound
but it's like deep in your ear so it
sounds like it's in your ear yeah i hate
it because it just sounds like someone's
just getting into your ear like that i
had like uh like a night
mold made you know like when you go to
bed you wear like one of those plastic
guards yeah i've got that as well
yeah yeah um i haven't worn it though so
that's that's good yeah
i forgot
about that i know sorry
my dad speaks english too far
i don't know it's really it was really
annoying to sleep with for a long time i
couldn't sleep with it in yeah it took
it took me about a week to get used to
yeah i woke up drooling everywhere with
it yeah yeah that's that's a normal
experience yeah
i think i think i didn't start snoring
until i started wearing my mouth guard
uh because it literally forced you to be
to be a mouth breather when you when you
sleep right because
yeah the gap between just like like push
my lung
i couldn't like breathe comfortably for
me why did you need to get it i don't
know my dentist was like you don't
really need it but it's good to just
prevent prevent uh dennis was just
trying to [ __ ] you over well i was like
300 bucks so i'm sure they were like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah you need this you need this they
were like they were like yeah i do you
grinding your teeth is an issue but it
might be so we can get a night guard
down if you just want to be careful and
we can out and i was like oh uh sure
yeah and then they did it and then i
just really didn't like it so i just
stopped using it because i grinded my
teeth as well but my doctor was like if
you don't have this guard your bottom
teeth are really gonna disappear
yeah like i i didn't really know about
it until uh until i started getting like
jaw problems so like i think like in my
mid to late 20s i started like getting
jaw problems where it felt like my
like sometimes i'd wake up and something
will like feel off or like slightly
dislocated or yeah it's hot yeah like i
like i i never i i didn't know that it
was an issue until i started getting the
issue and then uh i went to my dentist
and you're like uh yeah you grind your
teeth a [ __ ] ton and uh you need to wear
a mouth guard because uh your your bite
is going to get like more and more
deformed
i'm going to schedule an appointment
because i forgot to reply to that email
yeah yeah
i hated it when they did the mold thing
right they put like all that that gunk
in you yeah like the putty thing right
yeah it was so confusing figuring out
how to breathe for a second where i was
like wait [ __ ] my mouth is completely
like covered with this gunk how do i
breathe without my teeth it feels so
weird i wonder if that's how it feels
when you have like dentures i don't know
just like not having teeth it felt
really strange
also i remember that they were like do
whatever you do do not swallow right now
and then i've never had an urge to
swallow more of my life
is that a challenge
they're like blasting [ __ ] in your mouth
trying to clean up something like that
do not swallow i'm like [ __ ] that all i
can think about is swallowing this weird
liquid that smells like apples i want to
do it
he thinks i won't swallow but i will
swallow the poison
the next thing you'll say is don't
swallow
[Laughter]
that's true
it's awful i don't like dentists i don't
think anyone likes the dentist if they
do i don't like i don't think anyone
likes the hospital as well
um
well yes yeah
kids want to play on the the free ps2
that they have there
he talked about this
it used to be me yeah yeah i used to
like it but then the gamecube controls
were robbed yeah yeah i wish i went to
your hospital because my hospital didn't
have that [ __ ] at all
have you guys ever had to ride in an
ambulance no yeah i did like in japan
actually in japan yeah because like
aki's like aki had a like slight
accident right at our last place and uh
like it was pretty bad so like we had to
call the hospital and i was riding the
hospital
right in the hospital right running in
the hospital
i had to get an ambulance so so i was
running the ambulance late at night and
like because it was late at night the
closest hospital was closed right makes
no [ __ ] sense like you think
hospitals are open all the time yeah uh
so we had to go to like the next pho
this one so it was like a 15 20 minute
ride yeah um and uh luckily you know
like aki was okay like she was calming
down in the ambulance right and uh it
was so [ __ ] up because it's like in my
head during that whole ambulance ride
like 95 percent of my brain was like oh
god i hope you know ugly is okay and
sure you know we'll be able to get out
of this yeah yeah yeah and five percent
of my brain was like oh [ __ ] yeah i'm in
an ambulance
like whoa this is so cool i've never
been a one before this is what it looks
like oh [ __ ] i i always just feel really
bad i feel like i'm inconveniencing
these workers yeah even though even
though it's their
job yeah like
my leg could be broken oh [ __ ] i'm so
sorry for wasting your time yeah it's
really someone else has a heart attack
or something yeah i'm
i was in the emergency room i've never
been in the emeralds by the way but i
was in the emergency room and this guy
was just holding on to his thumb i
thought that was really [ __ ] weird
and he was really calm yeah he's holding
on to his thumb like this and his i
could see that holding on to his thumb
like his thumb was falling off his thumb
had been cut off and he was holding on
all like in his hand he was holding onto
his thumb what and he was like really
calm and they were talking to him being
like are you ready mr jones to go to the
and he was like yeah it's all right
i don't mind waiting a little bit it's
really weird
it's really strange because i didn't
realize what he was doing at first until
i like saw the bag of ice with it and
then he had a band-aid going around like
this and his hand was like like this
right like and he had like bandage going
around oh i just i just wanted him to be
like are you ready mr jones if you like
thumbs up haha
it's really weird i i've you know i was
like tv shows in the uk like like just
farmers who like had their arm like cut
off yeah
because like if there's one finger you
don't want to leave you don't want to
you don't want to do right you don't
want to freak out you want to be calm
that's true i feel like the more you
panic the the worse it is for everyone
so you're like calm down but i don't
know it's easier said than done yeah i
mean obviously like we've never i've
never been in that situation so it's
hard to like imagine how you'd react in
that situation because you've kind of
never been in that situation yeah it's
weird really because when i've been in
situations where i i feel like i have to
calm myself down afterwards i'm like is
that what you know you see people like
freaking out yeah are they like trying
to calm themselves down or like what's
going through their head it's just what
do you mean like when when i'm like
let's say like uh if i'm bleeding really
badly which has happened a few times or
something and i have hemophilia and my
my whole focus when i when it's happened
i remember distinctly is like i'm
literally just focusing on not freaking
out that's all i did yeah
and i'm like i'm like trying to keep it
together yeah i just think like i'm like
is that what everyone does i don't know
because there's no way to get into
someone else's mind right now
so i wonder like
when some has anything ever happened to
you where you're like really scared and
you're like freaking out probably not
like i've never had anything like life
threatening or anything like that so i i
wouldn't know myself how i would react
but if it's
if if i know how i react with a lot of
situations it's just
yeah calm
yeah it's like trying to force yourself
i don't know how to i don't know how the
the human mind is really [ __ ] weird
yeah like i'm like i i'm the kind of guy
who in stressful situations just say
nothing like i don't know like
like
okay this is going off tangent now but
like i don't i don't physically react
when like someone tries to try to jump
scare me a lot of the times right i
remember i remember like every time
there's a jump scare or anytime sydney
like tries to like prank jump scare me
like i like she goes ah like that or
something when i come out the shower or
whatever yeah and i'm and i'm just like
completely like [ __ ] determinate to
zero reaction and she's just like [ __ ]
you and i'm like haha sydney that's
right i had a [ __ ] [ __ ] whereas where
is inside i'm just like [ __ ] my life you
know like inside i'm like screaming my
[ __ ] heart out man so like i don't
know like he slowly
i am the complete opposite like i hate
it when someone comes around the corner
and like scares me like i always stop
myself from like throwing a fist out
because i'm like it's a threat oh no
it's not it's not okay thank god
my final flight is just like fight no no
no no okay i shouldn't i should
no but like but it's weird because when
i had to call the ambulance for rocky
i was like surprisingly calm i thought i
was gonna be because i'd never like
called the ambulance before right or
like you know because i didn't know what
the [ __ ] the procedure was right so the
first time i was calling i was in my
head i was like oh god what the [ __ ] am
i gonna say am i gonna stutter you know
what the hell's gonna happen but then by
the time i got finished i was like oh
that i was a lot calmer than i thought
domino's will be here in 15 minutes
honey don't worry about it i'm gonna
call the ambulance now oh [ __ ]
i'm sorry
oh you said ambulance oh i said
pepperoni
don't worry actually the double peperoni
pizza
it was surprisingly calming but then i
think it was for me i'm calm in the
moment but then when it's all over
that's when it all comes out yeah yeah
right so
to me i panic like post when everything
just kind of sinks in to be like holy
[ __ ] that [ __ ] happened and yeah i
went through all this [ __ ] and it's only
after the event has transpired that it
actually starts to sink in and i start
to feel the gravity of everything that's
happened yeah yeah at least to me
um i do have a question though because i
kind of remembered this uh in the
experience i had in the past week do you
guys get have you guys ever got some
fever dreams
would you buy a fever dream can you find
one for me
you have when you have a fever when you
have a really bad fever and you start
dreaming really weird [ __ ] because i
thought it was just a saying i thought
it was just a term of phrase right until
i started dating sydney who gets like
such some of like the most [ __ ]
weirdest fever dreams i've ever heard in
my life while conscious huh like all
like while i'll sleep
i'm like like okay okay so what are you
going to walk she's just [ __ ] ravens
like she's running around the apartment
or she asleep wakes up and then he's
like gone you don't believe this dream i
had i was president i don't think that's
a favorite dream i think that's just
like going psycho
can we get a
definition of where the dream comes from
okay so so when you have like when you
have a really bad fever obviously you
try to rest you your body tries to rest
right or at least some people's body
tries to rest um and and then you go to
sleep and you're like sweating you start
having a really bad fever you know as
your body tries to fight off this
illness and then some people or i'm
saying some people because the
experience i've seen it happen to is
with sydney and she'll just wake up
drenched full of sweat and was just like
honey i just saw connor in a bikini
running on the beach what the [ __ ] is
going on where am i right now like it's
it's she was saying she'll just wake up
and just say like the weirdest [ __ ]
[ __ ] that happened and i'm like like i'm
like what what what just happened and
she was like oh it was just a few and
that's that's believable actually that
is possible
that wasn't a fever dream that was just
an episode
yeah because like i've never had like a
single fever dream at all or like i
actually i've really ever dreamed the
the problem is no no it's it's no dream
because i think i'm the exact same way
whereas like i don't remember 99 of my
dreams
and it's [ __ ] up because it's like i i
remember i remember some mornings i wake
up and i'm like i remember having a
really good dream and then as i am
waking up and i'm trying to remember the
dream again i'm like yeah and it's wait
what the [ __ ] did i just dream about and
it's so weird because it it literally
like fades away right as i'm trying to
think about it
but all i remember is that
i had a good dream yeah but if he told
me to recite it i'd be like i don't know
i don't remember i like because to me i
think i feel like i've just rarely ever
dreamed i i don't know because like if i
have a dream oh you do dream everyone
dreams i'm i'm sure i do i'm sure i'm
sure i'm sure i do you're not a [ __ ]
reptile like you do dream anyway i'm
joey um
dream sleepers can experience when they
have a fever
i'm sure i've had a fever drinking so
sure yeah but they happen similar to
other dreams that can happen during any
stage of sleep
yeah it just seems like her dreams when
she has a fever is just like the wildest
ones you know it's so strange i don't
remember my dreams
very i very rarely remember them yeah
maybe like once every month yeah
i don't remember really yeah i probably
can only remember like two nightmares
but but but like if i have a dream i
like i remember the fact that i had a
dream but like most but most nights i
wake up and i'm just like i there was
there was just a void in my head there
was nothing there was nothing i dreamt
nothing can you can you feel the sense
of time passing when you're aware that
you're dreaming
yeah have you ever have you ever had a
lucid dream no i really want to though
those are the funnest ones i've only had
once i've only had it a few times i
think i've had situations where what i
wanted to happen in the dream during it
did happen but i feel like it's a battle
i don't know this is so hard to remember
this stuff this is what scientists have
been trying to like [ __ ] figure out
for like hundreds of years yeah i don't
know do you have you ever had a dream
that's like been so vivid
that it's kind of like just stuck with
you for like years and you can still
recite it because i don't remember like
most of my dreams
i have one nightmare i had when i was
little that i think is the reason why
i'm afraid of heights now right uh so
like you know how they say like you
can't die in your dream right yeah
because you've never experienced it
before i think that that's bs
well actually i thought it was bs2 until
i had time i pretty sure i'd die in a
lot of my dreams
[Music]
you're all right i don't know no no no
no no food voices
i've i've i've done one of those food
points i've i've definitely died in my
dreams but i've just woken up
immediately as i've done yeah yeah
really do you always wake up is that
like guaranteed i feel like i've reset i
don't [ __ ] know what
is it you just remember
you died for real
you respawning your dreams i'm pretty
sure i've respawned in my dream i'm near
certain i've respawned in my dream the
the only nightmare i've had that i can
still vividly remember is i it was a
really short dream but i was like flying
in my room
and then for some reason i just stopped
and then i
and then just i just picked a young joey
flying yeah i'm just like flying my room
like like that yeah uh and then i just
stopped i remember i stopped and our
house was like uh it was like two
stories and we had like this spiral
staircase that went down to like the
basement floor yeah and i remember i
just stopped and i looked down at the
spiral staircase and i just dropped
like head first
and i vividly remember
my face got about this close to the
ground and then okay
right and just [ __ ] myself
right and i think from that point on i
got afraid of heights huh because i
vividly remember the feeling of falling
and it was horrible
you your brain made a traumatic
experience for you yeah that's so
strange like like to me like the one
traumatic dream that i've had that has
stuck with me for years
was i remember i remember this one time
um i was living this dream right
and i would wake up in my bed in my room
that i was living at the time and i
would just go about my day right and
then
and then it would just be a normal day
and then something would happen that
would just be like out the ordinary like
i would see
i would see like
i would see like a twin
followed by another twin like i just
noticed a glitch in the matrix or
something and then as soon as i saw that
it would like the dream reset and i'd
wake up again i would and i would think
that i was in the real world and i would
go about my day and then i will notice
another glitch in the in reality it was
it's it's [ __ ] nightmare fuel because
like i literally i literally repeat this
cycle and every time i would get more
and more paranoid that i didn't know if
i was in the dream world or if i was
actually awake i was like i was like is
this a dream of because like i would go
about my day and
i remember the exact moment i woke up
was about the tenth time when i like i
like went through an entire day thinking
okay i'm awake i'm awake and i remember
going to the toilet
and i was uh i was um getting ready for
bed and i looked at the mirror and then
my reflection turned like
turned away and like i [ __ ] like
freaked out and then i woke up for real
like for real real wow and i think an
arias to film no no no no no no it
sounds like a cool film i woke up for
real real and i was [ __ ] myself
because i didn't i didn't believe the
fact that i was actually awake right it
it it literally [ __ ] with my mind for
like an entire few days because i
i went about those few days being like
where's the glitch where's when's it
gonna happen when's it gonna come out
we're twins yeah yeah
i don't know how my mind created such a
[ __ ] up situation that it literally
like [ __ ] up my mind in real life
maybe maybe i'm still in the dream maybe
maybe i'm just trash tasting
when you're when you're dreaming right
are you able so like you mentioned that
you like flying right yeah when i'm in
dreams and i like let's say i do
something that i know is is impossible
are you aware that you're like you know
it's impossible and that you're dreaming
because i often always get i'm aware
that it's impossible but i just
i i think because like lucid dreaming is
where it's like you're aware that you're
what you're doing
so you take full advantage of that i
thought lucid dreaming was where you
then controlled said dream yeah yeah
yeah i can't control cedric to me i know
i'm in a dream a lot of the time okay so
okay so i can't control my dream when
i'm in when i'm in lucid dreaming state
but it's more of like
it's it's more of like it's more like
you realize that you're in gta with
cheats on you know that's that's how i
imagine it right because
there have been times where i'm just
like oh [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] dreaming all
right let me let am i dreaming let me
try flying okay oh i'm flying now yeah
brilliant i'm [ __ ] dreaming this is
amazing that sounds like you have cheat
signs yeah i can't
because i don't have dreams often when i
do i yeah at some point in the dream i
figure out this is a dream
right like something will happen that
my brain chose to make happen but i also
am aware that that is not possible and
that i'm now aware that i'm in a dream
but it doesn't change how i behave like
i know that i'm in a dream but i still
go on the dream this is so strange
what's wrong with our brains
like i had this dream recently i can't
remember the fall of it i told i told
the dream on stream it was something
like um i i i was in a
situation where
i'd been falsely accused of stealing
this game cartridge yeah and then i was
then arrested for it and i was like no
i'm not getting arrested for this i
didn't i didn't steal it i refuse and so
then i then i like killed one of the
cops and like ran away because he was
trying to arrest me over the [ __ ]
game cartridge that i had nothing to do
and then it turned out into this like
massive shootout and stuff now then i
somehow kept uh getting away and then
eventually i got caught and then i went
to prison and then i understood i was in
a dream at this point so then somehow i
magically then got a phone it's like an
easy car i had this phone in prison that
i was then using to then play games and
stuff and like have a normal life in
prison yeah and i don't know why then my
charger broke and
i remember this happened and i was like
[ __ ] when my charges broke and then i
just skipped and i had a charger and i
was like great
it was awesome
i just skipped the point where my brain
had to like think hard enough to come up
with the reason why i needed the charger
i have the charger yeah this is great
this is i don't understand why this
happens though but did you realize it
was a dream or yeah about halfway
through the dream i understood it was a
dream yeah but i did but you did you
don't take advantage of it you're just i
don't know how to
like because i was about to say like i
love how in the dream you still got
arrested
this is incorrect actually i didn't get
the charger i got really this is where i
reset so i went to the roof of the
prison because i couldn't i couldn't get
a charger so i thought what's the
[ __ ] point if i can't play games yeah
i jumped off the roof of the prison and
then i reset in the prison
i died i died and then i just in my head
i remember there was a jump
i i remember i died and then i just
appeared back in the prison again with
the charged iphone with a new charger or
something it's like the worst version of
edge of tomorrow
terrible
i just don't know why this was happening
why i understood it was a dream why
can't i have some control over it
they're all [ __ ] dreams i always have
[ __ ] dreams
but at least you remember like
because to me like a lot of night like
say for example like last night right to
me it's like okay i'm falling asleep
falling asleep falling asleep one second
later oh it's 7 a.m yeah like there's i
i feel no perception of time no okay
when you wake up can you feel
the time without looking at the clock
yeah sometimes
yes but not accurately i feel like i'm
pretty [ __ ] good at it now i don't
know what happened
it depends on how good my sleep cycle is
at that time um sometimes like now it's
a bit [ __ ] up because uh kovit just
made me want to sleep all the time so
i'm just like okay now now i can't tell
because my body's constantly tired but
before then i would be like you know you
know sometimes you wake up and you're
like
it's gonna be 15 minutes before the
alarm goes yeah i mean you look at the
time every time you look at the time
you're like i'm i'm a [ __ ] genius
the reason why i asked do you know that
is because i was like in like if i asked
you no dreams right do you do you know
that there was a flow of time in your
dreams
see this is weird i know how much time
is passing in the dream in the real
world isn't this weird
how strange is that that's that's
against inception rules though because
like
we all
we all know we all know time passes slow
in the dream world so because i'll wake
up right after a dream or whatever and
you know it'd be like 5 00 a.m and then
i'd be like i like that dream i'm also
gonna go back to bed yeah and then i
know
when i'm in the dream how much time is
passing because when i wake up the exact
amount of time that i thought had passed
in the dream had passed in real life is
this so strange i think that's just your
subconscious might be like like counting
the time maybe yeah it's almost like an
alternate reality do you have a level
like you need to [ __ ] [ __ ] the match
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
i am vr
we all had vr in our minds in our
most strangest episodes we've ever done
which this is a weirdest topic
do you ever like have a really fun dream
and then you get actively pissed off
when you like wake up
oh my god i remember this i remember
some of like the funnest lucid dreams
i've had and then [ __ ] sydney wakes
up i was like god god let's cuddle and
i'm just like [ __ ] off sydney i'm flying
right now i'm flying sydney i was on
episode 24 and i was the botanist
the worst one for me is like when i'm
having a good dream because i don't
remember most my good dreams right yeah
yeah but it's like i remember i wake up
and i'm just like man i don't remember
what i just dreamed but
maybe if i go back to sleep i'll dream
it again
and so i go back to sleep and i don't
dream it again i was like no
it's gone forever like like to me to me
that there's a point right because to me
i've i've had it before where i've had
like really really fun dreams and i like
you half wake up but before your mind
fully wakes up you're like go back to
sleep and then sometimes i've been able
like to like reinsert myself into the
matrix right god i'm getting in the air
i'm going in i'm going
so i know sometimes like i wake up i'm
like if i go to if i go to sleep now if
i go to sleep right now i can go i can
jack back in and then like
i get so sad when i like try to [ __ ]
will myself to sleep because you know
when you try to will yourself to sleep
most of the time it doesn't [ __ ] work
right but sometimes like i just like try
to like will myself to sleep and five
minute passes i'm just like
i'm awake now [ __ ] my life this is the
this is the real world i think i used to
do that but i don't ever try that
anymore i think sometimes i'm like yeah
whatever just get on with it i'll just
i'll just stream it again tomorrow night
you have a theme to most your dreams or
your dreams because they say that your
dreams are normally like reoccurring-ish
sort of like they're similar
no events ah no not really for me
i just die in a lot of my dreams
i don't know what that says about me
yeah uh maybe some dream expert but even
that you know how people are like
dreamologists yeah the dreams uh they
they
your dream if whatever you do in the
dream there's a there's a real meaning
to it in real life
maybe i don't know like if you're
stressed out then you're dreaming about
your teeth falling out and stuff like
that something like that right where
they think that every single thing that
you can dream of has a real life
counterpart emotion that you're feeling
right there is to some extent but yeah
i'm like it's definitely too complex for
us yeah way too common science yeah i
get like really high
high concept dreams sometimes um like i
get like like i thought i told you like
the the the dream i just had but like
sometimes i just dream
and then i wake up and i'm just like
that's a really cool [ __ ] film idea
that's a really cool film
yeah
basically right you know it's uh i don't
know some
it's so weird something i i like i don't
know how my mind works because sometimes
i'm just like damn i dreamed that that
was such a cool [ __ ] idea what the
[ __ ]
how the [ __ ] did my mind come up with
that concept what language do you dream
it as as as because all three of us can
speak two languages right yeah like what
what language do you usually draw
english uh english for me is that i've
rarely like dreamed in time unless i've
unless it's when i'm like living in
thailand and i'm like using it more um
more often that's so weird like i
remember like 90 of my dreams are in
japanese
okay i don't know why what language do
you think in though
depends that's that's probably why
that's probably why right because like i
i
i don't normally think inside but
there's been points where i've lived in
thailand and then my thoughts start
getting like jumbled up and i start
start thinking in a different language
as well which is like it's it's really
like how do you describe thinking in a
different language as someone who only
speaks one language it's
i don't know how to like properly
describe it thinking about how you think
is also weird
now i'm like i'm like i don't talk to
myself when i think i don't think so but
maybe i do talk to myself and i think
i'm not sure some people can't though
all right
some people like physically can't think
out no
now that you're telling me that i'm
talking to myself while i'm thinking now
i'm doing it but i'm pretty sure i don't
do it i think i should do things
i don't i just don't think i just think
i'd talk to myself in my head out loud
if i talk yeah because i remember i
remember reading about you know deaf
people thinking in sign language and
that just like that blows my [ __ ]
mind you know it just i can't even like
come close to conceptualizing it you
know but i know i know it happens i know
people do it but like you know it's it's
it's so weird it's so weird to me this
episode is sponsored by expressvpn when
you use the bathroom you always close
the door behind you right of course you
don't want random passerby looking in on
you so why would you let people look in
on you when you go online using the
internet without expressvpn is like
going to the bathroom and not closing
the door did you know that your internet
service provider knows every single
website you visit and what's worse is
that they sell this information to ad
companies and tech giants who use your
data to target you is that why this
melts in my area well the good thing is
that expressvpn puts a stop to all of
that it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone i use expressvpn
on all of my devices it works on
everything phones laptops even routers
so everyone who shares your wi-fi can
still be protected even if they don't
have expressvpn and the best part is
using expressvpn is as easy as closing
the bathroom door you just fire up the
app click one button and then you're
protected so if you're like me and you
believe your online activity is your
business secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com trash taste today use our
exclusive link e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trash taste and you can get an extra
three months for free
back to the show i would i would love to
like be able to turn on my lucid dreams
if if i if i had that [ __ ] power i'd
be like
like that that is literally so it's not
normal for you to be aware you're in a
dream no
i didn't know that that's not normal are
you always aware yeah like most of the
time i'd say like 80 of the time i know
i'm in a dream oh my god are you serious
you're that kid at school that aces the
test without studying
why was this decision because
that's not because he knows he's in a
dream yeah but he can't control it yeah
i can't control it
that's like that's like getting the the
becoming a lucid dreamer without having
the fun part of being a lucid dreamer
it's weird because like i can i'm aware
i'm in a dream and i know that i can
like
i can want things i know i feel that i
want the thing in the dream yeah but it
doesn't always happen like i don't know
how that have you ever like had a
superpower when you're like in a dream
yeah
yeah many times define superpower but
then i die normally
too much power to handle
for one minute literally like in your
own mind you're playing on hard mode i
didn't realize it was that possible with
all these superpowers i guess i'll die
i'm trying to think because like yeah i
always know
some like i said always some i'd say 80
of the time i'm i'm i feel that
halfway through or some period in the
dream i know that i'm dreaming because
things don't add up in my head when i'm
in the dream yeah even it's weeks i feel
like i'm conscious in the dream so i
know what's happening and i know that
some things don't add up yeah and i'm
aware that i have the knowledge from my
normal human life right and i can i have
that instead dream so like if somebody
[ __ ] teleports behind me at some
point after that happens x amount of
times or something i'm aware then that
this is now not possible
yeah when i die
and i just poisoned
his recent mechanics that happens so
much in your dream what is this no no it
doesn't happen often but when it has
happened like if i die but i'm still
dreaming yeah i immediately know
that now i'm in a dream yeah because i
died because she died yeah and also
gender you can't reset really you know
what's weird as well
i don't know if this is a strange thing
but when i'm in danger yeah that's
normally a good way that i know because
i'm rarely in life am i ever in danger
in like weird situations right so being
in danger is like not a normal emotion i
ever feel
yeah i mean so when i end up coming
across it in the dream like if
somebody's chasing me that's normally
like a one really weird way that i get
like in tune with the fact that i'm in a
dream i yeah cause like i also like very
rarely dream for one but even more of it
is for me to get nightmares
i see all of mine like nearly nightmares
i wanna say like again eighty percent
probably in the bad things how do you
sleep at night i don't mind okay this is
the thing right when something bad's
happening to me in a dream i cause again
i know it's a dream i feel these
emotions towards it but then i also
because again i'm aware it's a dream i
have this weird sense of like oh i
should see what could happen
because i don't feel like it has any
improvements
on my actual emotions i'm aware that it
isn't is this strange is this normal i
mean i feel like if you have nightmares
that often yeah and uh that's the thing
i don't wake up from a nightmare being
like like in the movies well oh that's
why i always found that [ __ ] so dumb
because we're going for a nightmare
bad happens to me what no i wake up from
a nightmare i'm like oh shut my phone
no i wake up and like oh if it's like
really bad nightmares which i've had
every now and then like yeah i wake up
in an actual sweat i've had like my
entire life in every single aspect like
ruined in dreams before
and like waking up like that's good
i'm feeling better now
because i because when i wake up i feel
much better because i'm like oh goodness
no no no go because i i've had i've had
nightmares where something was like bad
has happened
and then you wake up and you just have
like this instant sigh of relief where
you're like yeah oh my god thank [ __ ] i
thought my life was like ruined yeah and
like it's it's going it's great it's
[ __ ] great i'm coffee in this thing
i'm not in jail my mom like i i'm i'm i
find like so many charging cables
i think i've had like a dream where i've
like literally had to tell my mom i'm
about to go to jail
like seeing her cry and break down i was
just like that's
crazy it's just like the
i wake up and i'm just like why does my
mind do this to me like that was like
the most heartbreaking feeling i've had
which is telling my mom i'm about to go
to jail and i remember her [ __ ]
crying and breaking down god me feeling
like a like a vegetable like the worst
[ __ ] human in the world i wake up and
i'm just like
i've never loved my life more than i
have now i've never felt more fulfilled
i've never had that so you so people in
your world have like really depth
emotion emotional ability yeah yeah yeah
yeah see that's weird because in mine
it's like i'm the only person who is
aware of like how emotions work and
everyone else seems to be like robotic
everyone's like an npc
kind of yeah like because when i the
depth isn't there so like even when my
parents are in the dream
the reason again it's another weird
thing the thing that gives it away
though
the thing that normally makes me not
enough world building yeah
this is another thing where it wakes me
like where i feel like i become again in
tune into the dream that i know it's a
dream is when people aren't acting the
way i i my brain knows they are but it's
weird right because my brain is the one
making this yeah so why does my brain
make the people like this but then in
the dream my brain also
it's like i'm playing checkers against
myself and i'm like fantastic move
connor you figured out the plan you know
what i mean it's like what is happening
in my brain
even when you sleep you try to beat
yourself
you're literally creating a you're
literally creating a game for you to
beat while you sleep like what is
happening the absolute stage
absolutely
like makes so much sense because i swear
every one of my dreams is like a [ __ ]
easter guy to me right
i literally get transported into my own
[ __ ] story in my own [ __ ] world
yeah there's depth in the world building
there there's like some high concept
[ __ ] dreams that i remember like
characters actually
characters in my dream actually act like
characters in real life
finally i can self-insult which is like
which is like sometimes when i wake up
and someone's like done like i remember
like one time i had a dream where sydney
murdered my family
and i remember waking up i remember
waking up just as like i like found her
don't wait i woke up and i turned to her
with such [ __ ] anger and you're like
you [ __ ] i can't believe you just did
that to my mom and dad
how dare you you better have a good
reason
i was about we were about to go to trial
i will see you in court
because like at the time like the
emotions felt so the emotions felt so
real to me that i i don't know like
sometimes when i woke when i wake up and
the dream isn't resolved i still have
like those emotions fresh in my body
yeah i fresh my mind like it's like hard
to like sometimes
get rid of it it's like it's like those
stereotypical like you know the
girlfriend dreams about the boyfriend
cheating the girlfriend's dream wakes up
soon that's the boyfriend it's like what
i've never understood that but now i do
i've never spoken about my dreams in
depth it's the first time i'm thinking
like oh yeah maybe my dreams are weird
maybe i'm the weirder i i thought i
didn't remember much of my dreams but
now that now that i'm thinking about it
maybe i do just remember a lot of
because i don't dream often but when i
do dream it's like an event for me you
know it's it's it's it's literally like
watching a film it's great it's great
this one's going into the mirror bank
also sometimes i have dreams that i at
least i can only remember
that are very brief dreams like
30 seconds of a dream that i can
remember and i've woken up yeah the
latest one i remember i was cooking me i
don't remember why yeah i didn't know i
was in that street
i just woke up and i was probably the
thing that gave me food poisoning i
don't know
i remember i was cooking meat and uh
food in your dreams
that's another thing i don't think i
ever get sick in my dreams from all the
ones i've remembered i don't think i've
ever gotten ill in a dream i don't think
i've ever well i mean you're you've gone
one step above and you just straight up
dying
i never die from like it's never like a
dream of me on the bed and i'm like
like it's yeah it's like i'm always
getting stabbed getting thrown getting
shot like
i mean in your dream you're
you should be in like your peak
performance like
your peak formula i think it'll be
pretty sad if your imagination is just
like now you're you're a frail
[ __ ] you're a frail [ __ ]
in your dreams now you can't fly how
many times would you like to die
i've had dreams that other people have
been sick in them and i've been around
just like the whole dream has been
around this person who's progressively
getting more ill yeah and that was those
dreams are really depressing yeah
because even though again i'm aware i'm
in a dream i can't do anything to help
them i feel like but i don't and i still
feel sad because seeing this dream sad
version that i've made up that i'm
getting more dead is really saddening
this is so strange this is really
bizarre i i think one of this is why
inception was so good i think one of the
weirdest i think one of the weirdest
dreams i had which actually would be
like a cool concept is i remember i
remember one time i like i i remember
one time i woke up and i for some reason
i was just i knew i was like the second
coming of christ
like i i'm like i knew i knew i was the
chosen one i knew i was the messiah
right i knew i was the messiah but the
problem is right so so i think that's
called the sigma male grant
so the problem is right the problem is i
knew i was the messiah yeah but for the
life of me i could not prove it to the
world right so so like so like i would
try to go outside every crazy guy
so i would go out and i would like
perform miracles i would i would go out
and i would like walk on water and [ __ ]
like this and then and i remember i
would be like guys i am the messiah and
everyone be like that's a magic trick
that's where where's the mirrors at
where's the mirror
and it was just it was just me
progressively getting more more and more
more angry i think i like even [ __ ]
went on joe rogan at one point in this
stream right to be like jesus christ
you're like i am jesus christ and you
guys proves it and i remember like i
turned the frog right now i remember i
took my hand out and i like i just like
made fire in my hand and he's like
that's not impressive i've i've seen
magicians do that
do something real do it do a real
miracle all i'm hearing is the the dream
god wasn't actually about
you becoming a god it was that you're
furious with the current state of magic
catching up to real life because it was
it was me thinking if there was an
actual messiah that got born into our
world
how would they go about proving it
what would like what would they be taken
visas
that was that was just like it is very
hard in the modern era yeah special
effects yeah now that you say that
someone's going to make a [ __ ] jesus
guy
literally take that concept so i
remember jesus
i was just like that's a really cool
concept i'm i'm glad my that was a cool
concept
copy right there right now yeah yeah now
that i've said it someone someone can go
write a story but i don't [ __ ] know
have you guys ever had sleep paralysis
yes one time one time yes i have
literally seen sleep paralysis demons
have you yes i have okay i've never seen
this with me
i've never gotten to the demon part but
i've definitely
had because i didn't believe in sleep
paralysis until i got it and it's so
[ __ ] weird because it's like
for those to explain what sleep
paralysis is basically you're awake but
your body's asleep yeah essentially so
your mind's awake but your body yeah so
like i believe when you go to sleep your
body like excretes like cremate uh your
mind is called a chemical okay your mind
is a chemical that paralyzes your body
while you're sleeping i believe
and so it's like some hunter hunter [ __ ]
yeah and and so what sleep paralysis is
is that that chemical is still in your
body so you can't like move but your
mind is still awake yeah it doesn't
sound right is that is that right ashley
can you can you can you google it
so basically uh it's basically
it's it's it's you're conscious
but you are not able to move yeah yeah
yeah so i i've only had it once in my
life and i thought this was nonsense
before yeah and it was like i i was it
was on joey's couch yeah really
yeah when
your sister was there your sister would
come and i remember it was weird because
they were speaking about me and i was
trying to get up yeah say hello but i
couldn't
i was face down on joey's couch
trying my best to wake up
i was fully aware i couldn't open my
eyes but i was fully awake and i
couldn't move my arms or legs yeah but
it didn't feel that like i was paralyzed
it felt that like even though i was like
willing my body to wake up like my arms
and my legs like my whole body wasn't
listening yeah i'll see your eyes were
closed because when i had sleep palaces
my eyes were open oh my eyes were closed
and i i could feel i was well aware that
i was awake and i was aware of
everything that was going on around me
yeah but i couldn't like it just took a
moment and i felt like there was a
battle when i was like telling myself to
wake up it like wasn't doing it like i'm
pulling a chainsaw cord you know yeah
yeah she's like i could feel that i was
trying to get through and it wasn't
happening i didn't understand why
eventually i woke up for me it was so
[ __ ] because like i remember i clearly
just remember opening my eyes looking
around i was like five in the morning i
saw the clock you know you could you
could you were looking
your eyes were moving around i was
literally i was darting my eyes around
and i'm like why can i not talk or hear
anything or move my body yeah oh sorry i
couldn't hear anything i couldn't hear
anything either i couldn't hear anything
i tried to like open my mouth to say
something and my mouth just wouldn't see
this is one of those things where i feel
like it's definitely the mind like this
is like a like a [ __ ] a glitch yeah
what what what the [ __ ] else do you
think it is the demons but like this is
why i think when he's like it's a
chemical i'm like i don't know there so
to me it just sounds like a a neuron
[ __ ] up in your head that's like really
like you hear that
so it's just like restarting like it's
like trying to figure out so what
happened did you go back to sleep after
your sleep players no no i woke up after
like 15-10 minutes yeah oh i went back
to sleep oh i because this was like i'd
had a full sleep and i was waking up and
i and i woke up and i just couldn't move
my arms or legs for a little bit it
wasn't like a
it wasn't like i was trying to move in
it wasn't moving like i couldn't even
like
like figure out how to move it right
really strange i don't understand how
this worked so i remember the one time i
got sleep paralysis and i literally saw
her sleep paralysis
what did it look like okay so i i called
it a sleep paralysis demon it just
looked like a ghost so what happened is
like uh so i was sleeping on my bed
and then like i like i remember like not
waking up immediately but yeah i
remember just like opening up my eyes a
bit and seeing like this kind of like
ghostly figure i was like what the [ __ ]
is that immediate like immediately i
like punch my eyes open and like i see
like this female figure like kind of
like praying above me or something
no but it was literally like this this
uh this like looked like a nun or
something that was just like praying
like above me and i start like freaking
out because i'm just like what the [ __ ]
there is a literal ghost floating above
me right now right right how old are you
i was around 24 okay yeah so it was i
wasn't young i was uh yeah
around 24. and i remember i remember
like i said i'm like i remember my mind
going into fight or flight mode just
like just like i was i started panicking
because obviously if you see like
[ __ ] ghosts floating above you you
start [ __ ] panicking so i like try to
start like moving my [ __ ] body to
like like do something and i remember my
body just would not move and it was like
it was [ __ ] it was a terrifying
experience right strange yeah it was it
was a terrifying [ __ ] experience and
i remember it took me about like 10
minutes 10 to 15 minutes of me like
screaming at my body it's like just like
ah gone move move you're gonna die
you're gonna die you're gonna die now
that sounds like a dream it could it
wasn't a dream because like it felt like
no because like it felt like a dream and
not like a dream at the same time right
because
i was obviously in my room but like
after about 10-15 minutes i actually
like
finally was just like able to will my
body to like just like sit up yeah i
remember i immediately sat up i looked
up and i could see like the the figure
just like literally fading away as i sat
up
it was like super super like [ __ ]
surreal so that's that's why i'm just
like oh that was at the [ __ ] sleep
paralysis even that everyone [ __ ]
memes about you mean that thing actually
exists what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's so weird oh that was like some
persona [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe it was just my stance
i don't know man you just lost your
standing
another question when you dream
do you see like visually see your
surroundings this exact same way because
i don't like i mean like when i'm okay
like i'm seeing this right now right i'm
seeing like the the real world in like i
don't it's it's like way fuzzier when i
see my dreams like i let's say i know
there's a table there yeah but i can't
like give you the detail of it like i
can i can
i know what everything is around me yeah
i know everything's around me but i
can't like visually see everything
that's happening really strange do you
have this as well no mine's mine's in
like [ __ ] rtx on 4k
60 fps why is it like a fisheye lens
that's that's why like for me that's
like like for me sometimes it's like so
hard for me to tell the difference
between when i'm dreaming and when i'm
awake because my dreams are so vivid and
so
i don't know like i said they have a lot
of depth to them that sometimes i wake
up and
sometimes i immediately know that i've
just woken up and sometimes it takes me
a few
few moments to realize okay i'm i'm
actually awake now this is the real
world i'm not i'm not in the dream world
anymore i think for me things that are
fuzzy is things that don't exist in
reality huh so it's like like if it's
like a table for instance then it's like
i can clearly see that it's a table but
if it's like a [ __ ] fairy then i'll
be then then it'll probably look fuzzy
well you know when you're you're trying
to remember a moment that happened yeah
right
you have a picture of it in your head
you don't have it like in 4k rtx the way
that you saw it right it's not this kind
of fuzzy
you remember where everything was you
think you you know what i mean yeah like
the way that you recall things that
happened it's kind of like that the way
i see stuff in dreams it's like i don't
see it perfectly like if i'm focusing on
like this table yeah i know god's there
for example but i can't like see gone
does that make sense
i know i'm aware that are there in the
dream i don't see them unless i'm then
paying attention to them
yeah because then your brain has to
render out right it's rendering
because because you know it's there but
like your brain's just like i didn't
want to render us out
i know that god's there i just don't
want to render it now you're going to
upgrade your brain's graphics
right
now right i don't need to see that joe's
in the corner of my eye yeah because
it's in the corner of my heart but when
i'm trying to remember the whole picture
in my head when i'm in the dream it's
like that yeah
rendering right right it's like a 1060
what's going on my draw distance is like
lowest possible
like when i'm walking up to the building
it starts to come in a frame it's like
it's it's a load of [ __ ] a weird [ __ ]
dream what a weird [ __ ]
it's like that though where like i the
dream doesn't exist unless i'm focusing
on it in the dream so have you ever had
a dream that's taken place in somewhere
that you're like very familiar with or
like somewhere like you know all of my
dreams are in places that i've been to
in real life right see most of most of
the time my dreams are in new places
that i'm not aware of
i don't know what it is i think my brain
is like
capable of coming up with new locations
what i think it is i think it's like
stitching together things that i've seen
passing right yeah yeah yeah and and
what i
you know like i can i can't
visualize a lot of things but i i just
know what's happening and i have an idea
it's really strange a lot of my dreams
are in my house they take place in my
house that's strange i never have dreams
in my house
but it's like all sorts of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happens
in my house that shouldn't work which
house like the house that i'm currently
in the
when your house start right i'm sure
it's not credit sequence
shot to door joey opens up hey guys you
know like where do you just wake the
dream it's like game start you just wait
you just like it starts in a weird ass
location and you're like what the [ __ ]
is going on no it's always it's always
mid-conversation
yeah i never remember the story i'm just
like oh wait what oh oh i guess we're
here now
because i i guess i already remember my
dreams when i realized i'm in a dream so
i never remember how i get there yeah
you know i did so i don't see like the
playstation
it's just like oh i'm in the game i'm
just like oh dreamcast starts brilliant
it's almost weird because i feel i feel
like when i'm dreaming i'm watching like
a video and at some point in the video
i'll know that's me does that make sense
like it's a series of events unfolding
yeah and i'm not necessarily constantly
in that brain of the person experiencing
it this is so strange right this is
really weird even even stranger question
have you ever dreamed in third person
yeah yeah okay okay that to me is like
the weirdest [ __ ] dream because like
like for some reason in my dream it
makes sense that i'm seeing myself in
third person yeah right
like for example like even though i've
never experienced that in my life yeah
that prison one yeah it was weird
because i remember
that's just gonna start to be strange i
had i remember shooting the guns right
right but then i also remember watching
me
after shooting the guns
so it flicks between first and third
place and i i and and the weird thing is
is that i then was able to feel the
emotions of both yeah when doing the
dream act and then when watching me do
the dream act yeah this is so this is so
strange i've never spoken about it i've
never spoken about this before you're
talking now that you're making me think
about this i'm realizing how weird this
sounds to say out loud like this must
sound so bizarre i don't know if anyone
else is i don't think a dream
conversation is going to be normal i've
never had a conversation just about my
dreams before with anyone but like so
the best way i can describe how it is
like is like you know when you're like
in playing halo right yeah and there's
that theater mode where just any point
you can just unclip from the keyboard
like just but i'm not choosing where the
camera goes but i'm seeing it from a
perspective and i don't understand who's
or what it is sometimes yeah sometimes
sometimes i have like amazing
cinematography
and i don't know i don't know how like
if only the youtube videos could match
yeah yeah yeah right like i don't know i
don't know how it happens but sometimes
i sometimes i'm in first person and then
i like i go to like a new a new like an
area or something and i have this this
really
area
a new area on the map or something and
i'm like my dream switches to like this
establishing shot of this like new this
new landscape and i'm in i know
and i'm just like i don't know and i
remember thinking in the dream damn that
looks cool as [ __ ] and then i load back
into my character or something
it's so i i don't know how to describe
it
your dream has cut scenes is that what
you're saying
this man's journey literally has
cutscenes and when it's over he goes
back into first person
it's
holy [ __ ] it's it's so it's i don't know
why like i think sometimes i dream in
games you dream sound like a kojima game
yeah sometimes i dream in games and
sometimes i dream in movies which is why
like it never makes sense to me how i
can possibly dream in third person and
like at the time it makes sense because
like you never see yourself in third
person my third person do you mean like
like in a movie like from a movie camera
standpoint or are we talking like gta
like behind yourself sometimes both
really yeah yeah yeah so yeah i think
it's
it's weird really because again i know
that i'm in this situation and i fully
understand that it's a dream but i never
ever like think that like this is wrong
yeah yeah because i'm in the moment and
it's what my mind is making up so it
always feels natural
when i'm in this dream like for some
reason i'm just [ __ ] remember this
now like talk to you guys
every time i'm in an interrogation room
i'm never like po it's never pov
interrogation room it's always
interrogation
it's always side view like this is
[ __ ] jcs criminal investigations or
something it's so it's so weird i don't
know why i mean like i do every anytime
i have a conversation in an
interrogation room i'm always in third
person i don't know why but
it always feels like i'm in control
of what i'm saying i'm sure that's
purely because we've just like consumed
media that where they portray those
things like that right so yeah yeah i'd
be interested to see
if another person who has never seen
like an interrogation scene in a movie
how they would because i've never been
in an interrogation in my life so that's
i guess it
kind of makes sense i i've also found
that if i'm highly anxious about
something when going to bed there's like
a 90 chance my dream is going to be
about that oh
that's only ever happened a few times
and that's only ever happened with
homework and exams
i was playing that uh pogo stock game
recently yeah and um did it give you
nightmares and i yeah i had like
nightmares that i was stuck in this game
and that i couldn't stop playing this
game because i couldn't beat it because
i was making i played it for like eight
hours and i made no progress
and then i went to bed all i could feel
was me playing the game in the dream and
then i was playing it and i was like i
couldn't get out it's horrible
that was nice
that was a horrible night
that that's a scarier nightmare than uh
you dying yeah the worst part was i knew
i was in a nightmare and i was getting
more annoyed because like why am i
wasting time where i could be actually
doing this but instead i'm in the
nightmare
stuck in a cycle playing in my
nightmares
do you ever have like moments where your
dream is so intense that you don't feel
like you've slept at all
yeah
like i wake up more tired yeah yeah yeah
i've never had that yeah because
sometimes because you go on such an
emotional journey in this dream or at
least i do that i wake up just like
exhausted so what do you do then just
get another eight hours huh i i don't i
like i get up but like i get up but like
my sometimes i just like feel like i
haven't slept at all just because i feel
like i was awake in my dreams so i
didn't really sleep at all i don't know
it's it's it's really weird yeah like
the worst nightmares i've had is i go to
sleep obviously tired and i'm probably
not in like a right state of mind yeah
before i go to bed hence the reason why
i have the nightmare and then i have
that nightmare i wake up in that [ __ ]
cold sweat like
[ __ ] you're so tired after that but i
don't want to go back to bed
because i know if i close my eyes right
now it's just going to be like to be
continued like it's just going to happen
again
where you have a fun dream you can never
get back into the dream yeah when you
have a nightmare nightmares
when you have a nightmare you go back to
sleep you re-enter the nightmare i think
it's like probably stress and stuff
right like it's probably
behind the tree like like freddie's like
hey guys
oh you're sleeping again nice yeah i
don't know why yeah i find it so much
easier to re-enter my nightmares than to
re-enter my fun dreams can i get a round
of applause everyone
because this episode is sponsored by
manscape they've just launched their
ultra premium collection believe it or
not it's for your not so private parts
i'm talking about a leveled up hygiene
routine with your favorite manly scent
this is an all-in-one skin and hair care
kit for the everyday man and covers you
from head to toe literally manscaped is
trusted below the waist now trust them
with the rest of your body we all know
how essential the manscaped lawnmower
4.0 is for that precise trim below the
waist but now you can enhance your
perfect grooming routine with the ultra
premium collection connor what does this
include i thought you'd never ask aunt
because it includes manscaped premium
deodorant no not for your balls for your
stanky armpits and don't forget their
body wash which will lather you up with
that infused aloe vera and sea salt
shower gel that sounds so nice and the
two in one shampoo and conditioner to
clean your scalp and finally a free gift
gentlemen a three pack set of lip balms
keep those choppers feeling moist
that's four products plus a gift inside
the ultra premium collection what a
score guys so get 20 off plus free
shipping by going to manscape.com
trashtaste that's 20 off plus free
shipping at manscape.com trash taste the
power of attraction is now in a bottle
thanks to manscaped these nuts
back to the episode okay so since we're
on the dream topic uh do you guys sleep
talk
yeah i should talk
really don't think i said generally just
this is going to sound terrible i just
screams
are you serious i like shouting probably
it's probably every time you die right
oh he died you've been around me right
while i've sleep talked right
um you don't i've never heard you sleep
talk i've heard you snore very heavily
yeah
like i don't know if you're screaming or
it's just a little
snoring or if it was crisp and snoring
like that
like not that loud
really did was did you ever like sleep
talk during when you did your sabbath on
and you slept on stream is there like i
muted the mic
oh
damn just in case i was fighting that
dragon that could only be defeated by
racism yeah
i i only asked because aki has recently
started sleep talking like a lot yeah
and i'm like kind of concerned because
uh sh by sleep talk she randomly shouts
out phrases that just don't make sense
when you think about it in a sequential
manner like i remember she's like cause
ugg is the kind of person who like
literally head touches the pillow three
seconds later she's snoring right like
instantly like that which i'm so [ __ ]
jealous of but then now it's gotten to
the point where like
three seconds after the head hits the
pillow start snoring five seconds later
she says a random thing
and like i thought the first time she
did it i thought she was joking right
because it happened in the span of like
10 seconds so i just started laughing
like i think i remember her like like
she's like all right good night goes to
sleep starts snoring and then she just
goes
legs
[Laughter]
i was like maybe maybe she's like
and then and then and then i started
laughing and i was like come on sweetie
what are you doing but she continues to
snore and i was like wait are you are
you serious and then she goes
butt fries
[Laughter]
and so i had to shake her awake i was
like are you are you [ __ ] with me
right now
and she wakes up and she's like
what time is it i was like it's been 20
seconds what are you on
because in her head it's like an hour
has passed or something yeah yeah that's
weird again like whenever i sleep i
always know how much time has passed
yeah
yeah i don't understand how yeah like
sydney has a lot of nightmares um when
she sleeps and like i can i i know when
she's going through a nightmare because
she's she's just in panic mode like i
can tell when she's running away from a
[ __ ] monster because she's like
i don't know because like i know when
that happens i have to wake her up and
be like you're in a nightmare honey
don't worry don't worry it's all so
you're in the safe zone i'm here i mean
is she like is she like when a dog has
like a dream of running and they're just
like stuck in place yes
she it's so it's so obvious it's so
obvious not only like when sydney's
dreaming but like the type of dream
she's having yeah because she won't say
words but she'll make noises depending
on the type of mood that she's in right
so if she's like having a nightmare
which is like most the time she she'll
like she'll like start like [ __ ]
panicking she'll have like a panic
attack in her dreams and all this [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] when she's like happy
she'll just like laugh and just smile
and all this [ __ ]
like it's it's so obvious to say like
sometimes i i see her and she's just
like has like the biggest smile on her
face i'm just like
i wish i was you right now sydney
because you're having a [ __ ] fun
dream right now i don't know why i don't
know why seeing someone with a huge
[ __ ] grin as they sleep is the
creepiest thing ever it's like could you
just like imagine walking into the room
and someone's just like
as they sleep like that that's really
creepy
i completely forgot i do actually some i
don't scream sometimes i physically like
laugh myself awake but something
something really funny happens or
someone says a really funny joke and i
actually like physically laugh and i'm
just like oh i was i was dreaming now
that you mentioned i think i've ever had
like funny dreams
i've never had a funny dream either have
you ever had funny dreams i don't know
wow that's so strange now that you've
mentioned that i'm depressed even in my
dreams it's always it's always something
[ __ ] extreme in my dreams yeah okay
it's never been like i've never had
funny dreams where i guess i'm in a deep
sleep but most of the times you know
have you ever had like a micro dream
yeah yeah where where you
where you it's it's when you're like
really really tired and you're not like
completely
it's so weird to describe because you
don't feel like you're completely asleep
but then you start hallucinating some
[ __ ] or like it's or like you you know
like a daydream like not not like a
daydream well what what does the
daydream county was you can't do for you
daydream is just like you're just bored
sitting there and you just start
imagining some [ __ ] no no no so like so
like you're you're like actually really
like physically tired and you start
going to sleep right so you're not like
you're not like completely in a deep
sleep but you still start dreaming as
well so it's like half you like it's hot
i would say like half a lucid dream
because it's so easy it's like sometimes
i wake myself up by like falling over
and you get like a [ __ ] jerk it's
like jerk and you're like yeah oh [ __ ]
the inception method the the inception
method and you're just like for [ __ ]
sake i was so i was so close to being
asleep and then i had to like jerk
myself awake yeah and then sometimes
someone says something funny in the in
that
brief micro dream and i like laughed
myself awake i was like for [ __ ] sake
i was i was so close to sleeping i was
so close to actually being asleep
i want to be there when you experience
that just to see how [ __ ] weird it is
from my perspective it's just like god
just like sitting there
i've never seen god do this yeah it's
weird no because it's it's it's like
because i've really i very rarely like
micro dream i don't know it's really
weird but you must have had the dream
where you've jerked yourself awake right
have you ever had that
you could have you could have phrased
that
your body literally jerks like because
you you like hallucinate that you're
is there another word i could use i feel
like that's the best
jolts okay jolt yourself jerk yourself
away yeah do you joke
oh thank god
i'm back baby oh thank god
george i've never used the word oh wake
up
i don't actually i don't think i've ever
used some [ __ ] synonyms for jokes
i've had uh i've had those like
stereotypical like on the train like
times where like you know you're just
closing your eyes because it's the long
train ride yeah you have that thing
where you fall forward
like that is that what you mean no i'm
talking about where you literally or
you're like literally in the dream
you're literally like you're literally
in half a dream and then you imagine
falling over or tripping over oh that
happens a lot yeah i do that my i like
kick my leg out or something yeah oh
yeah so that that's kind of what i'm
talking about but instead instead of
like imagining that i'm falling
sometimes i imagine someone saying
something funny or something funny
happening and then i just laugh
and then it's just like so it's like an
emotional joke yeah yeah it's like it's
like an emotional right yeah
i don't have that at all like like yeah
sometimes you know you imagine like a
ball flying towards you and then you
jerk yourself awake as well yeah that's
happened a lot that's happened a lot in
my dream as well yeah
like it's weak sometimes i won't be
dreaming of anything and then it will
very quickly cut to a ball being yeah
yeah i i i don't understand why i think
faster yeah i can literally like not be
in a dream not a dream not a dream and
then someone just flies at me and i'm
like
i just immediately fell asleep but it's
not like a full awake no that's what
that's what i mean it's like mike it's
like a micro dream right where you're
not fully asleep but you're not fully
awake and then you're your brain's just
like ah think fast
[ __ ]
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding you're
back
you're right
my uncle apparently used to be a really
really bad sleepwalker and sleep talker
like my dad would tell me stories of how
my uncle they because they they used to
sleep in like a bunch so bizarre isn't
it like it's such a crazy thing yeah and
he just like there was one time where
actually no i've i have a story of when
i sleep walked once uh yeah the only
time apparently that i ever sleepwalked
was when i was little like i was like
maybe four or five years old right and
apparently i walked into my parents room
and i was asleep and my mom saw her she
was like what the [ __ ] are you doing and
then she realized that i was my eyes
were closed and she was like oh [ __ ]
he's sleepwalking and i was saying
something to her but like it wasn't
really words i was kind of just like
woke up
and then the moment no the moment she
went wake up you dumb [ __ ] was when i
walked over to the corner of their room
and there was like a washing basket and
apparently i pulled my pants down into
it that's so weird okay okay
and then my mom was like
i have a worryingly similar story
not of
me so crazy yeah so my little brother
had a sleepover
and you know i was the one who was i'd
stay out of the way a little longer than
i should i was playing on my game boy
whatever
and uh our house the floorboards creak
really [ __ ] loudly yeah right and
obviously i've been in this house for
years so i could tell based off what
creek where someone was in the house and
where they were coming from
like and and what point they were on the
stairs what point they were like some
kind of [ __ ] daredevil [ __ ] except
only for my house
so
i heard someone who kept walking to the
middle of the like top of the stairs and
then back to my little brother's room
and then back to the stairs
and then back to the my little brother's
room like really slowly all right and
then after this happened twice i was
like what the [ __ ] so i went i watched
and he just walked
to the top of the stairs mumbled
something and then went back right what
the [ __ ] and then he went to the top of
the stairs and then i was getting
worried because i'm like what if he just
like falls down yeah yeah that's
dangerous so he just starts walking down
the stairs really slowly right and this
is where i was like what do i do because
i didn't know what you're supposed to do
when someone sleep walking yeah i've
heard loads of you've heard like myths
if you wake them up they can die yeah
you know so i was like
it seems like he's doing it okay i
didn't want to wake him up because what
if he wakes up he's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i would i'd [ __ ] yeah i jumped bro
you know like i was like [ __ ] what do i
do so i'm i i see that he starts walking
down the stairs but like doing this
thing where he's going back and forth so
i'm like huh and i saw that like he was
like mumbling so i was like i think he's
sleepwalking yeah so i go to follow him
and he's going down the stairs really
slowly and he gets to the bottom of the
stairs and so i go but i go to the
bottom of the stairs
and then he opens the door to the living
room and goes in the living room this is
like like the [ __ ] like i don't know
it's just like horror film you stood
there pitch black because i didn't turn
the lights off it was so scary all i had
was my game boy sp advance to like light
the thing
i didn't want to turn the lights on
because i didn't want to lie
yeah yeah literally like i was like the
shitty like max brightness slider up
kind of like figure out what's going on
and i see him and he's just standing
there mumbling for like a good like 10
20 seconds and i'm freaking out because
i'm like what do i do like do i go and
like uh like wake my little brother up
and tell my parents because i don't know
what he's going to do so i was just
watching him making sure bear man i was
like 14 15 yeah yeah i didn't know the
[ __ ] was going on and so he's he's
standing there in the middle of this
living room and then just slowly starts
like walking towards the tv and then
walking back to where he was then he
walks to the tv
and there's my video games all there
like in those one of those old 2000s
metal yeah
yeah
and then he just
starts pulling down his pants and then i
was like no no no
it's like not on my games
and that's where i woke him up and i was
like no no no no and then he woke up and
said well what what like that like it
was really weird how did he react to him
just like stan he acted like i was the
weirdo
i remember that i remember being like
what
he reacted like i was being weird like
because i was like stop stop like
shaking him you know i wasn't exactly
the same as well like my parents were
like what the [ __ ] are you doing and i'm
like what do you mean what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i look down on my pants
okay that makes sense
but he was undoing now and that's where
i was like you're not pissing on my
[ __ ] ps2
my pants like fully down my hand was on
my dick and i was like i was like ready
so when you woke up did you momentarily
think like they were the weirdos yeah
okay see that's okay i was like i was
like
because i looked over and my mom was
like really worried
i didn't even really know this kid i
barely knew him so i was like we never
really like whenever i saw him it was
always awkward after that because he
just always remembered that time where
he woke up and i was like what the [ __ ]
he always pissed on your games yeah yeah
based on my ps2 collection my my wii
probably i don't know what it is
did you ever get the point where like
there's something happening
in like in like um in the real world
where like you hear a sound or something
or like you need to go through the
toilet and it gets like integrated into
your dream for like a good while uh
i don't know if maybe but i probably
don't remember it like like
the most annoying thing for me is is
when i need to go to the toilet in my
dream because i don't immediately wake
up yeah when i go to the toilet i want
to need to go to the toilet but like
luckily they're luckily my brain has a
disconnect between my body and my brain
because there has been several times
right where i've really really needed
there's been several times where i've
really really needed to piss and like in
my dream i don't know i'm dreaming but i
acknowledge the fact that i really
really need to piss right so yeah i've
had several like five minute pisses in
my dreams and the and the feeling of the
piss just won't go away because
obviously i'm only pissing in my dream
and not in real life so i'm like i'm
like i'm like urinating and i'm like i
get so frustrated in my dream because no
matter how much i urinate the feeling of
needing needing to urinate never goes
away that's really weird yeah if i feel
something if i if i piss myself in my
dream i'm pissing myself from yeah i'm
just like that's that's how i'm
appreciating happening i almost [ __ ]
myself doing that one
how can you replicate the feeling of
pissing so accurately in the dream yeah
without without actually pissing yeah
that's i can't replicate
feelings
i know that it's not accurate in the
dream
yeah yeah when i get when i get punched
in a dream it doesn't feel like a real
punch i can distinguish between that
yeah okay no i like
for me it's so short for me you must be
able to
inception fifth level dream yeah i'm not
getting this [ __ ] what are you
experiencing
i'm like i i i i i'm like that i'm like
so what
i'm like five level deep holy five
levels
i'm like i'm like in front of this
urinal pissing and i'm just like why is
the feeling of urinating not going away
holy [ __ ] why why am i pissed is there
an establishment of the toilet as well
before you start you're like level 10
dreaming i'm a level two this is insane
yeah i don't know and it's like i'm just
like
at some point in the dream i just give
up on trying to get rid of this
urination i go on with a dream and then
i wake up and being like
oh
that's why i needed to piss because it
was a dream and i need to piss in real
life and you hadn't pissed your pants no
i hadn't pissed my pants and then okay
and i have like the most satisfying piss
in my life because like yeah because for
me like every time i've had a dream when
i was a kid of going to the toilet i
have 100 pissed my pants
like i wake up and i'm just like
and you know because of that one time i
was [ __ ] myself while i was asleep
here's the problem of uh growing up with
a bidet your whole life
and uh with this heated toilet seat is
the fact that it's just as a kid you're
just ingrained into your head of war oh
my butt is warm i'm sitting on a toilet
so in my dream i'm on the toilet and i
can feel that my butt is warm right
because it's a heated toilet seat yeah
so in my head i'm like oh but warm i'm
on a toilet this is reality i'm actually
going to take a [ __ ]
and uh and so in my dream i i almost i
remember i almost start taking a [ __ ]
but then i was like something's not
right
why why can't i not [ __ ] right now i
it's like i had the feeling that i
needed to [ __ ] yeah but i couldn't like
nothing was coming out and it wasn't
like a constipation type of thing it was
like literally like i know i need to
[ __ ] but nothing's coming out right and
then i woke up [ __ ] and i was like oh
now i actually need a [ __ ] like i was
like prairie dogging
i was like oh god i was this close to
[ __ ] myself it's like very strange
i'm in my dream i'm able to communicate
to like my non-dream brain being like oh
you need to piss oh no no so i can like
i can stop the dream if i need to pee
like i can go oh there's been so many
instances where i know i'm in a dream
like i'm in a nightmare no it's every
time i'm in a nightmare i know i'm in a
nightmare i can't wake up i'm just like
go on wake up now please wake up like i
remember i remember one time i was
getting chased by this murderer or
someone like that it was like it was
like a scene out of uh what's that jack
nicholson film the shining like it was
like the scene out of the shiny one i'm
like getting chased by [ __ ] jack
nicholson or something yeah and i knew i
was in a nightmare yeah i just didn't
want to experience dying yeah right in
the dream because it still felt real
yeah of course and i'm just like go on
wake up
nothing happens i'm like god i know
you're dreaming right now i know you're
[ __ ] dreaming [ __ ] murderer like
goes around the corner
start [ __ ] liking it and i'm like god
i know you're dreaming right now wake up
another and my body refused to wake up
until i died and it was
i don't know why my brain is such an
[ __ ] that i can't wake myself up like
now you want to experience this
but i can only force like choose to wake
up when i need to pee or [ __ ] okay okay
oh i can't even do that so i can like
in the dream i'll feel it and i know
that when i'm experiencing this dream
that i can feel this like a sensation
yeah and i know that i can i need to do
it yeah i won't stop the dream unless i
get to a point where it feels
uncomfortable and then i think i'll just
be like
you're on like 5g i'm on like dial up i
don't know like i'm just like i'm just
like you need a pierce you need a pistol
my brain's like all right hold on
sending the most code right now it's
going to take a while weird man
that's too late
i'm sure people in the comments have
like even weirder drinks i'm i'm curious
now because i don't i don't think i've
ever seen i've had such an in-depth talk
about my dreams
before i know i didn't i didn't even
know it was not i thought it was normal
that you knew you were in a dream no i i
thought that was normal yeah that's a
lucid dream that's why they call it a
loser
i thought everyone had that because
that's the mainly the ones i have i've
tried like using methods to lucid dream
because there's like tutorials of like
here's how to lose a dream and one of
them was like cut a ping pong ball in
half and put them on your eye
people want to lucid dream yeah why yeah
because they want to control their
dreams right they want to do whatever
they want they dream because most people
when they know they're in a dream can
control their dreams yeah like i have no
like 99 times out of a hundred i have no
control of my dreams it's what i have
when i have lucy control your dream
so you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
just like your imagination just [ __ ]
do it normally do it awake
no i can't fly in my dreams i can't like
i can't like [ __ ]
like run a million miles an hour i can't
if my brain forces me to like experience
it yeah but i can't like i can't just be
like all right tonight i'm gonna dream
about
i don't know [ __ ] 100 [ __ ] like i
can't i can't do that doesn't that take
away the excitement of dreams if you
choose what you're doing
no it just means like i said it's
literally to me it's like playing gta
with cheats on where you just where you
just like have fun like to me i just
it's just having like fun in this open
world
like at that point like people are npcs
when i've realized that this is a dream
and i'm just like
i can do whatever i want i can fly to a
different city i can
yeah i can jack cars it's [ __ ] great
i have so much fun
yeah
i would i would be interested in
someone's psychoanalyzing our dreams
yeah honestly like because we all
obviously have three different
perspectives on how we dream and uh how
i like the experiences we have when we
dream
this has been a very bizarre episode of
trash tastes dremologists out there as
they call them yeah dream moles
like a disney job
yeah what are your experience with
dreams dude do you relate to us do you
have something entirely different let us
know because
yeah generally because i've never heard
of anyone really talking about their
dreams in depth um strange and yeah this
is the first this is this is the first
time for me as well wow these are weird
yeah
you know what isn't weird though our
patrons hell yeah i bet they have
awesome dreams hell yeah
they can control their dreams
just like you can control yourself by
supporting us on patreon at
also follow us on twitter since he means
on the subreddit and if you had our face
listen to us on spotify i can't wait for
the [ __ ] memes of this episode of
like the [ __ ] wacky [ __ ] dreams
that we've had
it's gonna be like the wildest dream of
the world is weak in the subreddit oh my
god
yeah but the that's been this uh dream
filled episode of trash taste don't
worry this wasn't a dream
this entire episode has felt like a
[ __ ] fever dream that's how this
episode started actually i'm talking
about waking myself up from the stream
sorry to piss all right everyone guys
bye
[Music]
you